Ihr hört,
CRE Technik Kultur Gesellschaft mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur 218 Ausgabe dieser kleinen Gesprächsreihe wo man sich über Dinge unterhält die ich gerade interessant finde.
Und ja heute wollte ich mal so ein bisschen mich den Kronjuwelen des Podcasting zuwenden,
zweierlei Hinsicht einerseits sind,
ist das Thema heute sind Diamanten und ja andererseits freue ich mich hier ein kollegen begrüßen zu können so kann man das glaube ich sagen nämlich den Reinhard Reinhard remfort.
Hallo freue mich sehr hier sein zu dürfen in der Metaebene.
Ich freue mich auch sehr dass du dass wir das hinbekommen haben ich hatte Dich schon so bisschen länger auf KiKa weil du ja der auch ganz und umtriebig im im Podcast Geschäft bist aber nicht nur deshalb.
Machst ja mit deinem Kollegen Nikolai zusammen methodisch inkorrekt woher als halt gebildete Physik.
Zu erklären von euch.
Ja tatsächlich ja Wissenschaft ist ja ein sehr sehr komplexes Thema und selbst als Wissenschaftler also setzt man wissenschaftlich arbeitet sieht man immer nur einen sehr sehr kleinen Ausschnitt beansprucht war aber dabei immer.
Ja mehr zu zeigen.
Weil wenn wir durchgehend nur bevor sie kriegen würden wir das ja sehr langweilig außerdem gibt's dadurch dass wir bemerkt hingeben MadAss mehr Themen reden mehr Diskussion.
Mit Menschen die uns korrigieren.
Ja und ich denke auch dass es ein besonderen Wert hat eigentlich in so also wenn man sich selber als Wissenschaftler versteht das tut er natürlich dann auch in die Breite zu gehen weil.
Hat ja auch mal so ein bisschen diesen Stereotyp des des des des Nerds der jetzt tut sie nur so sein eigenes Fach kennt.
Ihre Fachidiot Haltner.
Fahrräder genau der ist wo man das Abi nicht in Relation setzen kann und ich habe auch immer bei Gesprächen,
so auch mein Podcast aber auch sonst oft trifft man halt auf Leute,
die die sind zwar in ihrem Fach vollkommen drin und und und und haben dieses diese Sache für sich verstanden,
aber einerseits fehlt oft natürlich an der Eloquenz das dann auch mal richtig herzuleiten und wie auszubreiten und auch halbwegs didaktisch aufzubauen und was mir aber meistens noch mehr stört ist diese mangelnde Kontextualisierung,
wie einfach aus so einem Mangel aus Kenntnissen von anderen Domänen Konto.
Ja das dass er sich in das Schwierige ist immer wenn man der Wissenschaft irgendwas irgendwie McLaren möchte sich immer wieder bewusst zu machen was für ein selbstverständlich ist was für andere Leute nicht selbstverständlich ist.
Also dass man sich in die andere Person hineinversetzen was werden Informationen fehlt weil diesen Blick verliert man sehr sehr schnell wenn man sich nie irgendwas halt gut auskennt.
Also,
lass uns mal Spiel als Physiker wenn man Leuten irgendwas zu Kristallen oder so erklären möchte erstmal erklären sollte was ein Atom ist oder so weil das halt so er macht immer von der Schule gelernt so ja ich habe auch in der Schule mal irgendwann Goethe gelesen kann ich heute auch nichts mehr von ne.
Ich war ja der Waldorfschule das Atom nicht erklären.
Hermann hat dran geleckt oder.
Ja keine Ahnung man hat rum rum getanzt oder so sich wie eins gefühlt verloren in der Weite des Universums.
Wie bist du denn so groß geworden also ich meine was hat dich denn so in diese Richtung gelenkt denkst du denn.
Matrizen Wissenschaftler zu werden.
Ja so so ja überhaupt diesen diesen,
diese Richtung sozusagen zunehmen bevor ich jetzt gleich zu irgendeiner Berufs oder Studienentscheidung gekommen ist also wie willst du denn so der Welt begegnet woran kannst du dich erinnern.
Ich bin also woran woran kann ich mich erinnern ich bin als Familienmensch aufgewachsen durch und durch also ich habe vier Geschwister,
und Familie war bei uns immer sehr also hatte und hat immer noch ein sehr sehr hohen Stellenwert.
Meiner Mutter war es immer sehr wichtig dass ich Sachen lerne.
Also der war Bildung unglaublich wichtig und mein Vater fand alles gut was meine Mama gemacht hat.
Wie das so üblich ist manchmal meine Mutter,
camzap aber nicht aus einer auf einem ja Akademiker Haushalt oder so oder generell meine ganze Familie nicht,
und Wissenschaft ist in meiner Familie auch in keinster Weise irgendwie verdreht,
sage ich mal ich falle da tatsächlich sehr aus der Reihe hatte aber eine sehr also,
auch wenn keine besonders reiche Kindheit sondern eher so das typische Arbeiterkind aus dem Ruhrpott eine sehr behütete Kindheit und ja Eltern eine Familie die sich in jeder Hinsicht aufgeopfert haben,
für was meine Eltern haben sich Pappe gesehen aufgeopfert für uns als Kinder und versucht uns halt zu ermöglichen was halt irgendwie ging.
Und meiner Mutter war wohl sehr früh sehr bewusst dass ein Schlüssel dazu Bildung sein kann.
Das hat meine Mutter extrem viel wert und zumindest bei bei meinem Mann der Bruder mir darauf gelegt dass wir halt ja nach Möglichkeit irgendwie Abitur machen wenn es geht und.
Ja 80 dann gefreut Halte dass wir studieren wollten oder das gemacht haben hat uns aber nie zu irgendwas gezwungen sagen immer so du musst studieren gehen sondern,
egal was wir gemacht haben soll sie hat uns immer unterstützt also auf ich gesagt hätte nee ich will nicht studieren gehen,
Ich will weiß ich nicht Schreiner werden oder sind meine Mutter auch gesagt so ja dann mach es super finde ich gut und Wertung,
ich glaube ein bisschen schon in die Richtung geschubst so dass wir halt irgendwas in die Richtung machen möchten.
Aber immer nur unterstützen nie irgendwie mit Zwang oder ähnlichem und das hat sich in unterschiedliche Richtungen entwickelt wenn man das so sagen möchte,
meine Geschwister haben zum größten Teil soziale Berufe also von Altenpflegerin Kindergärtner und ähnlichen bisschen zu meinem Bruder der,
mit dem ich mich sehr sehr gut verstehe denn nur ein Jahr älter ist als ich aber wir haben uns,
Kindheit komplett zusammen verbracht und Wareneinkauf sowas über seine Brüder und beste Freunde,
und dieser Bruder ist Religionslehrer geworden also das Lehrer für katholische Religion und Erdkunde,
und ich bin Physiker geworden also dafür trotzdem können wir uns immer noch super unterhalten,
verstehen uns auch immer noch aber es gab zumindest keinerlei keinerlei Prägung in irgendeiner Form dass man sagt ich bin,
durch meine Erziehung oder durch,
also nicht weil ich dachte mache was auch mein mein Vater meine Mutter gemacht hat irgendwie in dieser in diesem Topf gefallen diese Richtung so die frühesten Sachen an die ich mich erinner ist irgendwie dass ich Sendung mit der Maus mal toll fand.
Cool wenn ich furze lass mich verstehen habe verstanden habe die Sachen funktionieren ich fange,
bei Zauberern wollte ich immer wissen wie das geht nicht ich wollte mich nicht verzaubern lassen soll mich wollte rausfinden wie funktioniert das,
und ich ja ich erzähl mal ganz gerne Geschichte wie ich so einen Kopf gefallen bin und das Interesse geweckt wurde,
meine meine Mutter war sehr sehr katholisch,
und Sergius auch und hat mich als kleinen dicken Jungen immer mit auf den Friedhof genommen sonntags nach der Messe geht man auf den Friedhof und macht der Oma ein Lichtlein an.
Weil die Oma muss ja nicht im Dunkeln liegen.
Genau und dazu zu der Zeit hat meine Mutter mich hat sie gesagt immer mitgenommen und ich hatte natürlich eigentlich so als kleiner Junge gar keinen Bock,
draufhalten der er doof Neumann will Sonntag im Bett liegen oder vom Fernseher sitzen und Zeichentrickfilme gucken oder so.
Meine Mutti hat aber verstanden mir das trotzdem halt jetzt schmackhaft zu machen und zwar da hast du kleine Renato Rechenspiele auf dem Friedhof ist das klingt auf dem Kontext gerissen wahrscheinlich sehr komisch,
meine Mutter hat mir anhand der der fällt und Reinzeichnungen auf dem Friedhof also so ein Friedhof ist ja organisiert wieso ein Kleingartenverein nur weniger Grillwurst & mehr Tote,
da hat man immer Felder und rein an die Gräber zu teilen und diese Felder sind nummeriert gewesen auf dem Friedhof und hat meine Mutter mir bevor ich in die Schule kam schon Zahlen beigebracht.
Dass die Zahlen an konnte habe ich halt gelernt wie man die addiert man subtrahiert und so ich glaube das hat mich sehr früh geprägt auf Matte für mich nie ein großes Problem war.
Weil ich.
Weiß ich nicht dass ich musste für für Mathe zumindest in der Schule also bis zum Abitur nie irgendwie was machen dass du mir immer super leicht befallen weil das für mich was selbstverständlich ist und sehr leichtes war.
Würde ich mal unterstellen dass das sagen so eine frühe abstraktions Einführung war.
Genau dass das kann gut sehr gut sein und,
ja da war meiner Mutti im auf dem Friedhof und die am Grab meiner Oma darf mit Grablampe die hatte so schreiben an der Seite die so spitz angeschmissen waren,
und im Winter wenn die Sonne relativ tief steht,
dann führte dazu dass auf dem Grab so Regenbogen artig halt bunte buntes Licht war weil es hat gebrochen wurde natürlich.
Im Prisma meine Mutter mir einmal erzählt das hat der liebe Gott gemacht weil er sich so freut ja.
Die religiösen sind manchmal wirklich zu beneiden in ihrer einfachen Erklärung.
Ja aber meine meine Mutti das das fand ich auch sehr schön also meine Mutti fand's toll dass ich Physiker geworden bin und.
Ich habe meiner Mutter da auch glaube ich viel zu verdanken weil meine Mutti in dieser Richtung Null Grundbildung hatte also garnichts die hatte halt damals nach dem Krieg in die Volksschule mit ein paar Jahren gemacht und das war's dann,
uns.
Ja ich hatte immer die Gelegenheit jemand also ich hatte immer jemand zu Hause sitzen den es interessiert hat was ich tue und dem ich das erklären konnte und das habe ich auch mal gemacht also ich habe,
zumindest am Anfang des Studiums noch in der Schule meiner Mutti immer erklärt so was ich mache und warum ich das toll finden also was ich an Physik toll finde ich an meiner Mutti Atommodelle erklärt,
und Bronze ich glaube das hat mir selbst auch viel geholfen das zu verstehen selber.
Das ist die alte Weisheit nichts versteht man besser als wenn man eine Lage ist jemand an.
Ja ist das zu erklären ja genau.
Was ist die beste Schule und denke keine keine Prüfung der Welt und kein Formular in der Hinsicht und Multiple-Choice-Verfahren.
Kanne ähnliche Stellung vornehmen ich hatte das auch ähnlich dass ich.
Bettwäsche Deutsch glaube ich erst in dem Moment verstanden als die Sprache so die Grammatik und alles als ich angefangen habe mir für selbst ausgedachte Rollenspiel Regelwerk zu schreiben.
Sag mir dann auch wie auch so viel Spaß bereitet die Zugkraft des Geschirrspülers gespielt worden aber,
auf dieser eigene Zwang jetzt das auch total in Ordnung zu bringen der sozialen ist richtig zu tun und dann darüber in diesem Prozess hands-on quasi seine eigenen Erfolgserlebnisse,
zu generieren das Badhaus mal mehr wert als eine andere Einführung.
So eine Anwendung für das wissen dass man sich angeeignet hat es ist ja auch also in meinem Fall war es halt meiner Mutti was erklären und beim Programmieren ist ja auch so wenn du ein Problem hast dass du lösen willst lernt sich das Programmieren deutlich einfacher als wenn du dir ein Buch nimmst und.
Und viel effizienter und schneller.
Genau versuch's irgendwie dir die Regeln da ein zu blau.
Genauso mal es gibt ja auch viel Diskussion ist jetzt nicht unbedingt unser Thema heute aber es gibt ja viel Diskussion so in wie soll man Bildung halt künftig,
Tutorien und ich denke es tut schon not dass man sich halt so eine Schulzeit bis ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt,
sehr viel mehr so,
projektorientiert interessengeleitet modelliert um einfach auch das Interesse zu zu wecken und damit wahrscheinlich zu ganz anderen Ergebnissen zu, chatten irgendein.
Stoff ab zu haken denn am Ende eh keiner interessiert mich auch keiner mehr.
Ja genau das ist oder kurz merken und dann aber irgendwann wieder weg also.
Genau ich habe gerade den Vertrag von jemand gehört den Satz bildung ist das was übrig bleibt wenn du alles was in der Schule.
Was hat diese schöne trifft glaube ich auch ganz gut.
Wer trifft ganz gut wird uns heute auch noch mal so ein bisschen beschäftigen du hast ja dann die Physiker Laufbahn eingeschlagen in Duisburg ne.
Ja mit einem kurzen Umweg über den Maschinenbau in Bochum.
Ich hatte das auch in also eigentlich immer was mir sehr am Herzen liegt dass ich immer den ich habe letztens einen Vortrag in der Schule Gehalt,
nach langer Zeit mal wieder was ich versuche den Schülern immer mitzugeben bei mir war es damals so nach dem Abitur Katthult dieses typische Berufsberatung damit man halt so macht Berufsinformationszentrum.
Ruf Beratung beim Arbeit.
Ja genau genau das Fuchs und.
Man hat in der Schule glaubt das Problem dass man eigentlich keinen Job kennt außerdem der Eltern und den Job des Lehrers weil man die anderen Job halt nicht erlebt,
na mein alter Mann hat als als Jugendlicher oder als Schüler ja wenig mit anderen Jobs zu tun also wer trifft mal Maschinenbauer,
irgendein Zeitpunkt und begleitet den meine Woche oder so ja es gibt zu Praktika die Mama macht aber so wirklich viel ist das halt nicht und ich dachte halt damals nach der Schule so ja du willst du wissen wie Sachen funktionieren und.
Irgendwie mal was braun oder so Maschinenbau wäre doch die richtige Variante das habe ich ein Semester gemacht und an danach dachte ich so,
einsam studieren Ansicht liegen,
wird vielleicht besser im zweiten Semester habe ich dann gemerkt nein das wird nicht besser dass das falsch ist nicht das richtige für mich also,
habe mich insgesamt dabei Richtung wohlgefühlt also Maschinenbauer für Leute die es gerne machen finde ich super aber mir lag sowas für Konstruktion sag mir nicht so richtig also,
ging kann ich aber nicht so geil also hat nicht so viel Spaß gemacht woran ich richtig viel Spaß hatte bei Werkstofftechnik,
Werkstofftechnik von nicht cool da hatte ich sie also gings und Materialien dann ging es um Kristalle dagegen zum Aufbau Chemie fand ich auch super wie auch super gemacht und habe danach nach 2 Semestern gerade okay.
Dann machst du wohl doch mal das was dich so auch immer irgendwie interessiert wo du immer dran hängen bleibst machst du matin maximal Physik.
Und ich wusste dass das mit Mathe mehr wird und Mathe war bei Maschinenbau schon doof.
Aber irgendwie jetzt im Nachhinein was dann doch das richtige ich habe während meines Studiums auch viel gekotzt und viel geheult aber.
Ich will auch nicht sagen dass du die Studienzeit die beste Zeit meines Lebens war bei weitem nicht,
aber wir machen dann was dann doch das richtige ja ich bin dann in genau in Duisburg bzw damals noch essen die Uni sehr fusioniert irgendwann,
im beim Physikstudium gelandet noch einer der letzten Diplom Studenten dies Monster ab.
Und wie kam es dann zu dieser Spezialisierung auf Diamanten.
Es gibt in der Physik ja im Groben wenn man mal drauf guckt zwei Teilbereiche gibt theoretische Physik.
Ohne flutex metallphysik,
da hatte das Jan Philipp zymny mal was schönes zugesagt in einem seiner Texte der textile Physik ist schön niemand braucht Physik,
da hat er gesagt irgendwie sowas wie Ex und heilt Physiker sind die die die großen Maschinen bauen um zu zeigen dass die Kreide Triple von den Theoretikern stimmen oder so,
unser das Ergebnis davon ist dann entweder die kritzel Stimmen von den Theoretikern oder die Maschine war nicht groß genug.
Wieso es gibt juridicas nächsten Tag Physiker Theoretiker sind sehr mathelastig ich habe mich für die instrumental Richtung entschieden,
und ja wie wie man sich häufig so am Ende seines Studiums dann für eine spezialisierungs Richtung entscheidet man findet irgendwie einen Proft ganz gut oder man macht ein Themengebiet meinem Profil,
Gernot guck mal was der Sohn seine Arbeitsgruppe macht und landet dann da bei mir war's meinen Vertiefung Gebiet Vakuumtechnik.
Im Physikstudium das ist eine Vorlesung die ist optional ich finde aber die sollte jeder mal gehört haben weil Physik heutzutage spielt sich ihnen ich würde mal sagen 90 % aller Fälle in vacuum ab.
Also Physik Labore sehen immer so aus dass ein riesiges Teil kann man in den halt irgendwie Vakuum gezogen wird weil wenn man.
Halbleitertechnik machen möchte Oberflächenphysik oder so dann stört halt die Luft die muss weg also muss da Vakuum hin und zwar nicht einfach nur Vakuum so eine von der Staubsauger sondern da ist ein bisschen mehr Technik hinter soso die Geschichte von Vakuumtechnik darüber kannst du auch noch mal irgendwann Cre mit jemand anders machen.
Vakuumtechnik ist auch ein unglaublich spannende spannendes Thema weil mit Fortschritt in der Vakuumtechnik auch immer fette Sprünge in der halt in der in der Technik an sich einhergehen,
das.
Ja Vakuumtechnik fand ich halt unglaublich spannend habe ich dir super gerne gemacht bei dem Bruch von dieser Proft hat sich neben vielen anderen Sachen seit Jahren mit der.
Ja mit Diamant Epitaxie also der synthetischen Herstellung von Diamant beschäftigt bzw dem Werkstoff Diamant,
und nachdem ich dann da ein bisschen gearbeitet habe in der Arbeitsgruppe habe ich immer meine Diplomarbeit halt angefangen und da ging's dann um polykristallin Diamant,
auf Silizium so bin ich zu Diamant gekommen und irgendwann einmal damit angefangen hat dann lässt einen dass du nicht mehr so schnell los dann fängt man halt an sich in One Themar einzuladen wie man so schön sagt.
Generell oder ist jetzt spezifisch bei den Diamanten.
Nicht aber generell also generell bei wenn man im Studium irgendwie so in Richtung seine Abschlussarbeit geht wenn man einmal was gefunden hat was einem so was ein interessiert dann bleibt man dabei also die wenigsten Leute vielleicht hat sie das auch geändert mit diesem Bachelor Master gezeugt aber die wenigsten Leute die ich kenne haben irgendwie nach ihrer Diplomarbeit dann komplett,
um kompletten Schwenk gemacht in der andere Richtung bei ihrer Doktorarbeit oder ähnliches sandymaus eigentlich auf dem was du gelernt hast weiter auf und gehst immer tiefer rein.
Ist ja auch nachvollziehbar.
Ja genau das ist aber irgendwie Frage kurze Antwort eines Fall er wird bin zufällig bei Diamanten gelandet und fand das spannend.
Wir sind ja so Diamanten sind ja irgendwie nicht irgendein Ding so so in unserer.
Kulturlandschaft ist es so Symbol für alles mögliche für Luxus.
Für Perfektion für Einheit Härte nicht was du da noch einfallen allerlei Zeug sowas ja auch mal so Assoziation mit.
Wie wie man es sein will.
Diamond Status.
Ja genau ist es immer noch mal so eine noch mal so ein bisschen toller und klingt wie auch noch besser als Platin wo.
Genau da geht nichts mehr drüber das so ja.
Platin se so komisch mit Gold da waren die Leute auch eine Menge anfangen so Platin sei angeblich teurer und keiner weiß so richtig warum eigentlich.
So auch bei Diamanten gehen dann irgendwie alle mit und das ist auch das was man gerne auf seinem smartphone einsammeln wenn man alle Bushaltestelle wartet.
Eine Währung in diversen in diversen Spielen.
Ja so aus dem Team wird immer ein gewisser Wert zugeordnet was ich so bitte das dann auch noch Rolle also ich meine dass das vielleicht so ein Grund warum das um die auch noch mal einen mehr zieht.
Ganz am Anfang ja ganz am Anfang dachte ich Bock keine Diamanten machen ne weil das halt so krass das ist du das auch so sowas das ist was unglaublich teures ne und da.
Ja genau das ein bisschen weg Geld drucken aber es hat geil du machst Diamanten ne ganz am Anfang war das so da habe ich auch mich tierisch darüber gefreut nach ner Zeit wird Diamant wenn du damit,
täglich arbeiten quasi sehr wieder also wird alltäglich tatsächlich und Diamant ist für dich halt dann.
Ich habe genug Geld verdient hast dann spielt sie auch nur noch Golf.
Genau das ist ja,
das auch übrigens eine der häufigsten Fragen die ich gestellt bekommen wenn irgendjemand also wenn man dorfpartys ist und sich unterhält und die Leute fangen und was machst du so oder womit hast du dich einer Doktorarbeit Geschäftsführer Diplomarbeiten und somit andere Studenten damals zusammenbeißen und sagst also ja ich muss und diamanten die erste Frage die,
immer kommt es ja kannst also kann man die dann auch verkaufen also man damit reich nein wird man nicht sonst.
Sie will es jetzt nicht hier sitzen.
Doch wahrscheinlich würde ich trotzdem hier sitzen.
Nee Mann Mann wird damit nicht reicht wenn man wenn man sich damit halten hier beschäftigt und gerade so als als Physiker dann in die Richtung geht dann ist sie Diamant später immer noch fasziniert aber diese ganze Wert Geschichte des ganz kulturelles vollkommen egal spielt überhaupt gar keine Rolle,
kannst immer noch toll wenn ich in Museen gehe und in welchem berühmten Diamanten sehr besonders große besonders farbig oder sowas dass ich dich immer noch so mit Ehrfurcht vor weil ist halt,
geiles Teil aber.
Was denn auch so ein bisschen so mit diesen ganzen kulturellen drumherum,
beschäftigt dass ich meine Katze diese Diamanten Industrie und und die Förderung gezittert das hat ja so seine also einerseits hat Susanne gloriosen Seiten so die Kronjuwelen.
Ja genau ne.
Palastes na dann hat sie sein zu Business oder Mama so in Antwerpen war merkt man irgendwie.
Großen Großteil der Kronjuwelen ist übrigens sind Teile des größten Diamanten der je gefunden wurde.
Also ist ja mal so wenn wenn so ein riesiger Rohdiamant gefunden wird der wird eigentlich nie zu einem Diamant geschliffen sein wird immer gespalten und dann mehrere Steine verteilt und viele.
Da fragst du mich was das so da bin ich überfragt da muss ich meinen da musst du wahrscheinlich einmal mit dem Diamantschleifer reden weil man Diamant ja nicht beliebig bearbeiten kann sondern das geht immer,
Soda,
Kannst aufgebaut ist und die also wenn man bei Wert von Diamanten,
der Schliff auch ein Großteil des Wertes also wie ein Diamant geschliffen ist,
bestimmt auch wieder funkelt welche wie farbig der aussieht und zwar jetzt nicht die Farbe des Kristalls aber in welchen Farben der Funke,
ist sehr sehr viel vom Schliff abhängig und das Diamantschloss müssen sehr hohe Kunst weil es ist ja eins der härtesten Materialien ist die wir kennen das härteste natürliche Mineral dass wir kennen und das ist lässt sich nicht so gerne und vielleicht bearbeiten.
Und zwar bei großenstein ist es häufig so dass die gespalten werden und dann in in,
verbal immer noch große Diamanten aber in kleinere geschliffen werden so sondern bei den Kronjuwelen die sind ja auch schon älter,
ich weiß nicht was heute anders machen würde.
Aber wie spaltet man den Sohn Diamanten wenn er so furchtbar hart ist.
Dazu müssten wir erstmal klären wieso ein Waffen Diamant überhaupt ist woraus der aufgebaut ist und wieder aufgebaut ist Diamant an sich das wissen ja wahrscheinlich die meisten besteht aus Kohlenstoff.
Neueste einsteigen irgendwie indem.
Das können wir gerne machen sofort also ohne ohne zu klein wie ein Diamant aufgebaut ist wird schwer zu erklären warum man einen jemand nicht beliebig spalten kann.
Okay dann machen wir das gleich noch mal ich wollte nur noch mal so bisschen Diesel meine Erlebniswelt die ist sehr eingeschränkt also ich kann mich nur erinnern wann war das Antwerp Antwerpen ist das eines der X.
Sojasauce des Handels auf jeden Fall ja genau.
So na das ist ja so schon so ein bisschen weiß ich ob verrufen das richtige Adjektiv ist aber.
Hätte jetzt etwas ehrwürdiges.
Sicherlich auch ja das glaube ich halt so ein bisschen von von von von beiden etwas so aber der ganze diamanthandel hat ja dann auch die kommen ja auch alle irgendwoher,
Sodia,
wann sie hast du irgendeinen Teil davon auch mal näher angeschaut was du mal so auf Reisen hast immer so eine diamantmine aus der Nähe.
Sehen selber ein Haus.
Leider nicht dafür muss man ja auch an sehr entlegene Orte Großteil der Diamanten kommt jetzt mal Schluss Afrika,
aus großen Löchern die wir in die Erde buddeln oder Australien oder Kanada Kanada weiß ich nicht wie viel da jetzt abgebaut wird aber der wurde relativ spät auch zuerst Diamant gefunden man kann so als Faustregel häufig sagen Diamanten kommen,
leider häufig aus Gebieten die politische problematische sind also das,
wo Bürgerkrieg herrscht oder ähnliches also oder sera Länder die an sich sehr arm sind aber halt Diamant als Bodenschatz haben,
dann aber auch nicht die Bevölkerung also das ganze Land quasi sondern ein großer eine große Firma häufig irgendwas,
was kolonial geschichtlich schon so gewachsen ist und,
Diamanten sind zwar sehr groß und so weiter haben aber auch immer so ein.
Ja Blut dran kleben ist weiß ich nicht ob das zu dramatisch ist aber die Bedingungen unter sowas unter dem sowas abgebaut wird sind nicht die besten.
Und man muss verdammt viel Erde bewegen um einen Diamant darauf zu finden also rauszukriegen ich glaube dir eine der größten diamantminen gehört zu den großen Löchern die die Menschen die.
Gegraben haben genau also Diamanten an sich sind gar nicht so selten wie man da sind schon sehr sehr,
aber jetzt nicht so selten wie man glauben könnte also es werden schon ein paar Tonnen im Jahr gefördert von dem Zeug.
Ponon okay.
Ja oder verquickt nichts na also Kohlenstoff das liegt halt nicht viel.
Aber dieses ja was wir mit Diamant verbinden dass das doch wertvoll ist und so selten und so das haben wir hauptsächlich einer Firma namens DBS zu verdanken,
die auch zwingen also die einer der größten diamanthändler der Welt ist die heimlichen ungelernt in den 50er 60er Jahren ein unglaublich gutes Marketing gehabt,
und auch sehr aggressives Marketing gemacht es gibt ja das hat vielleicht der ein oder andere auch mal gehört zu der Verlobungsring wollte ja nach Möglichkeit an Diamantring sein gerade so im amerikanischen Raum ist das häufig und der sollte so von der Größe her so 2 bis 3 Monatsgehälter,
wert sein das ist zurückzuführen auf dem Werbeslogan von Dipperz.
Vivara.
Ja das ging genauso in die Richtung dazu the diamonds are forever Diamanten sind für immer und Diamant Verlobungsring oder einen Diamanten Ring sollte halt so 2-3 Monate.
Damit auch forever das ist ja das ist ja James Bond eingebrockt.
Ja ja.
Shirley Bassey nachdem wir mal zu schreiben will aber das war so die Zeit ne.
Ja ja ja genau genau das beste Favo.
Ja genau du da da ist es halt so das ist halt größer geworden das Diamanten Wiki was besonderes wertvolles waren.
Davon habe ich nicht so viel mitbekommen außer diese Erfurt die man halt mitgebracht hat an sich mal Diamant halt für für Reichtum irgendwie steht beim Thema geblieben bin ich halt als Physiker weil Diamanten geiles Materialist.
Weißt du denn wann behaupten dass die Frau komme ich jetzt gerade erst wann also seit wann hat denn die Menschheit überhaupt so sagen die Kenntnis dass die Dinger wirklich existieren erstmal.
Oh schon das schon relativ lang also da sind wir auch schon ich glaube also ich will nichts falsches sagen aber da sind wir schon so mehrere hundert oder tausend Jahre vor unserer Zeitrechnung hat man schon,
Diamanten da kommt ja auch der Name her der Name kommt aus dem aus dem Altgriechischen glaube ich von Adamas unbezwingbar.
Halt ein harter Stein und da hat.
Ich glaube nicht Plinius war es damals schon irgendwie hatte diverse Zitate zugesagt.
Plinius plinius der Jüngere oder der Ältere.
Was ist der der Mission Lateinunterricht immer gequält habe.
8er.
Ich glaube der hat irgendwas gesagt wie,
der der Diamant ist irgendwie sowohl dass das edel also der edelste unter den Materialien oder so der hat halt schon verschiedene Materialien und so nach Härte eingeteilt,
unser der Diamant ist im schon aufgefallen also das härteste und also Diamanten kennen wir als Menschheit schon sehr lange,
dafür aber so exzessiv als Schmuckstein benutzt wurde ist eine eher jüngere Geschichte da sind wir im 19 Jahrhundert rum weil man da erstmal zu Diamanten wirklich schleifen Konto mit man Diamanten schleifen unseren Rohdiamant nimmt ist das Halten relativ und Speck,
polieren Ding Ballack funkelt nicht das sieht aus wie ein klobiges Stück Glas da ist halt nichts mit fein und toll und Feuer und ähnliches.
Und deshalb waren Schmucksteine eigene also wann Diamant als Schmuckstein ist so bis man angefangen hat halt die Ohren sich schleifen zu können waren Diamanten als Schmuckstein er.
Nicht so wollte man nicht.
Und und und womit konnte man die dann also ich meine welche technologische Errungenschaft war der erforderlich um die dann auch schleifen zu können.
Das Verständnis z.b. wie die aufgebaut sind dass sie halt nur in bestimmten Richtungen spaltbar sind und dass man Diamant z.b. auch mit Diamant ganz gut bearbeiten kann also mit Diamantpulver schleifen und so weiter.
Was anderes kommt da nicht durch.
Es gibt mittlerweile auch synthetische Sachen es gibt Sachen also,
verschiedene synthetische Verbindung die man herstellen kann die härter sind als Diamant so Kohlenstoffnanoröhrchen eine bestimmte Richtung kubisches Bornitrid einer bestimmten Modifikation kann härter sein als Diamant.
Viabuy.
Nee nee nee,
dini nicht in diese Richtung sondern das ist er das Verständnis in welche Richtungen also in welchen Ebenen man Diamanten z.b. spalten kann in welche Richtung das geht da die aber nicht das Verständnis geholfen also man wusste noch nicht wie Diamant strukturell Atome aufgebaut ist aber die Erfahrung,
mit der Zeitung Mann hat mal eben hatte mal versucht und oh ja in die Richtung geht.
Und das geht erst seit wann ungefähr.
Also 1800 irgendwann hat man damit so angefangen dass das ordentlich.
Okay das heißt man kann sagen die Dinger sind zwar gefunden worden aber man konnte herzlich wenig damit anfangen also irgendjemand wird da so okay ist jetzt mal sehr habe ich versucht irgendwas auszubauen hat nicht geklappt schön lege ich mal die Ecke aber.
Also so so richtig richtig nutzbar also dass man Diamant als Material so richtig nutzt würde ich sagen ist erst so mit dem mit dem,
19 Jahrhundert bekommen also eigentlich sogar er eigentlich sogar erst mit dem späten 20 Jahrhundert als Mann in der Lage war Diamant synthetisch herzustellen auch,
dass der technischen nutzen dann auch richtig.
Bitte indische nutzen okay aber so als Luxusobjekt war es natürlich vor.
Subjekt vorher schon ja.
Aber natürlich erstmal nur so dem alle in der Regel zu gefallen dann.
Kronjuwelen et cetera und dann dauert es ja wahrscheinlich auch noch eine Zeit bis ich dann eben soll auch das passende Handwerk darum entwickelt hat um dann eben auch,
rufe Dich in diese Präzision zu kommen aber so dass das dann eben quasi mit dieser technischen Entwicklung irgendwann dann soweit war das dann dieser Laden gesagt hat okay jetzt machen wir mal aus Diamanten auch was populäres,
und dann ebenso dieses diese Sichtweise auf dass das jetzt so quasi der ist der Inbegriff des Luxus ist das der jetzt erstrebenswert ist und hat dann entsprechende Begehrlichkeiten.
Ist also mit mit ordentlich Marketing Inhalt.
Das ganze beliebte macht sozialen Gesteine dann auch als man sie spalten und ordentlich schleifen konnte halt auch so geschliffen dass man man hat ja wenn man Rohdiamanten findet der ist ja meist nicht hübsch.
Sondern da das noch ein Schlüssel drin von anderen Gesteinen also irgendwie dunkle Stellen und Sohn die will man ja auch weg haben das noch ein Grund wo man so große Steine spaltet z.b.
um halt so.
Und nur ein Schluss und ähnliches rauszubekommen danach werden die amanha unternahm auch noch bewertet heutzutage ob die lupenrein sind da auch ein schöner Begriff der auch so in den Sprachgebrauch übergegangen ist.
Dachte es kommt von den Tieren.
Das nicht von dir Mann an sich aber von Edelsteinen das was halt lupenrein ist.
Also wenn man mit der Lupe reinschaut.
O&f sauber also damit keine Einschlüsse unter 3.
Genau so wie lupenreine Demokraten.
Lupenreine Demokraten ja die auch häufig also da wir noch viele Diamanten gefördert ja.
Wenn es jetzt solche Fördergebiete gibt dann heißt das ja auch dass nicht jede Stelle der Welt in der Lage ist so Diamanten hervorzubringen oder ist es immer nur eine Frage wie groß der Aufwand ist um daran zu kommen uns gibt es eigentlich überall.
Die gibt es auch also es gibt im Grunde auf jedem Kontinent Diamanten also mittlerweile wo noch auf jedem Kontinent Diamanten gefunden,
aber es gibt halt irgendwo mehr Diamant vorkommt dass es sich auch lohnt den tatsächlich zu fördern das liegt daran dass Diamant in der Natur wahrscheinlich so richtig 100% weiß man das nicht,
also mein Mann hat Modell wie voll heute so in der in der Naturwissenschaft ist und hat eine Idee wie Diamant entstehen man geht davon aus dass die in der oberen Erdkruste halt mit Magma,
mit viel Druck halt mit viel Druck und viel Temperatur entstehen und dann mit vulkanische Aktivität halt nach oben gespült werden,
und dann halt an die Oberfläche oder zumindestens obersten Erdschichten kommen.
Wann findet.
Man findet Diamant da wo viel wird angezeigt ist oder mal Vulkan gezeugt war.
Wenn man sich das auf Nahaufnahme Weltkarte anguckt mal dürfte man das auch so an in der Nähe der der Plattengrenzen z.b. also da da wo halt viel Magmar und ähnliches mit nach oben kommt.
Diamanten also natürliche diamanten entstehen halt im Erdinnern,
bzw in den äußeren Erdschichten also so nah die ersten paar Kilometer wir kennen uns ja so über unsere Erde wissen wir ja garnicht soviel zumindest.
Genau in wissen wir nicht soviel daher auch was man auch nicht so 100% wie und wo diamanten entstehen aber so das Ringmodell ist mit viel Druck und viel Temperatur halt im Inneren der Erde weil da ist Diamant die unter den Bedingungen stabile Form von Kohlenstoff,
sag mir auch gleich noch kurz zuhört,
und da entsteht Diamant und der wird dann halt relativ schnell bei halt vulkanische Aktivität oder ähnlichem alt an die Oberfläche gebracht und bleibt stabil.
Das finden wir dann in Form von Diamant deshalb ist Diamant auch häufig eingeschlossen in anderem vulkanischen Gestein.
Was man auseinander klopft und dann Vito 111 jemand drin.
Ja okay soll es heißt die die die Schwerpunkte sind Afrika Australien.
Russland ja genau.
Ist das also vulkanisch.
Ja
Genau genau das teil.
Canis von daher lässt sich das schwer zuordnen nicht überall da wo es heute blubbert.
Nein genau nicht da wo's überall blubbert gibt auch Diamanten aber man findet es in vulkanischen Gestein also ihr also.
Das muss man sozusagen schon mal haben.
Ja da ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr hoch dass also nein nicht sehr hoch aber hör dass man welchen findet.
Was immer noch eine riesige Industrie und ist die Nachfrage nach Naturdiamant ist auch ungebrochen weils so das echte ist.
So jetzt ist Commission zum. Naturdiamant was ist denn Naturdiamant.
Na ja ich würde jetzt sagen das was man halt so ausgräbt.
Dann könnten wir es gerne Diamant den man in der Erde finden weil synthet also synthetischer Diamant und Naturdiamant unterscheiden sich nicht.
Diamant ist also da kann man spitzfindig sein und sagen ja doch tun sie weil verschiedene Gründe aber aus physikalischer Sicht ist Diamant erstmal nur eine Kristallstruktur.
Also die unterscheiden sich so sehr nicht dass man dann dem Endprodukt auch gar nicht ansieht dass sie unterschiedlicher Natur sind.
Richtig also wenn also.
Es gibt da ist so dass man gerade die großen diamanthändler natürlich auch sehr sehr stark involviert was Forschung und so angeht halt Möglichkeiten zu finden sind ethische Diamanten von denen aus der Mine zu unterscheiden,
wann ist aber heutzutage in der Lage Diamanten sauberer herzustellen als es die Natur kann also die diamantendiebe herstellen können sind sauberer als die die es in der Natur gibt.
Und etwas dreckiger zu machen ist selten ein Problem das heißt.
Man hat einfach noch ein paar Verunreinigung rein und.
Im Grunde im Grunde könnte man das tun also du kannst einem Diamanten wenn du ihn untersucht halt anhand seiner Verunreinigung hast du sozusagen einen Finger ab,
Termine wo er herkommt.
Also jeder Diamant und also jeder Diamant also Diamanten jetzt verschiedenen mincom unterscheiden sich in ihren Verunreinigungen.
Wenn du aber das Profil quasi kennst dann kannst du ja versuchen das halt zu imitieren.
Also Profil im Sinne von was für Materialien sind da drin zu Finn.
Genau was für Material in welcher Menge und so weil wie gesagt was dreckiger machen ist nie so das Problem.
Das können wir ja alle von ihrer Wohnung.
Genau ja richtig.
Also das hat diese Unterscheidung natürlicher Diamant und nicht natürlicher Diamant kann man machen aber dann sollte man dabei betonen dass der natürliche Diamant halt bedeutet der den man ausgebuddelt hat.
Dreckige Diamant mit jeder Hinsicht.
Ja das ja tatsächlich.
Aber trotzdem scheint sich das ja noch zu lohnen.
Ja tatsächlich und zwar liegt das unter anderem an ja am Menschen an an der Einstellung von Diamant an sich weil wenn du nimm die haben aber wenn du monde,
Menschen hat saghir das ist ein echter Diamant das einfach bei dem reddingen 1,
Diamant im Sinne von der Mutter SAMINA in Afrika von Kleinkindern rausgekramt oder so dann ist das für die Menschen wertvoll wenn du den sagst du so ein echter Diamant aus dem Labor,
dann klingt das so nach Massenware und das ist für die Leute halt nichts mehr wert.
Das heißt wie viel der Diamant wert ist so wie bei vielen anderen Sachen aus auch entscheidet was die Leute also wird von den Leuten entschieden die dafür Geld auf den Tisch.
Ja ist das denn Massenware wird es denn man in Massen hergestellt.
Was genau also schön Diamant als Schmuck also Diamant ja das ist wie ein Diamant natürlich finden DECT maximal so20 30 % von dem was sein bedarf gibt.
Das Material also ohne synthetischen Diamant Kämpfe heute nicht mehr über die Runden.
Okay und ist der Aufwand die man jetzt dann finanziell in das herausholen von alten Beständen steckt.
Es lohnt sich immer noch ne also es lohnt sich immer noch das als Schmuckstein zu verkaufen weil du halt genau dieses Problem hast dass die synthetischen Diamanten obwohl sie physikalisch gesehen das gleiche sind,
halt nichts oder weniger wert sind für die Menschen das ist das große Problem.
Wir mich denke man es heute soweit man müsste keine Diamanten mehr aus dem ihnen rauskramen.
Du bist nicht auf den technischen Bedarf zu decken.
Die auch nicht den also ihr wenn die wenn die Menschen verstehen würden das ist auch echter Diamant ist dann wird's auch für den schmuckbedarf reichen.
Ich bin auf der festen Überzeugung dass synthetische Diamanten auf Umwegen in INSCHMUCK landen da bin ich mir sehr sicher.
Weil es so einfach ein Zug von lockendes zu großes Geschäft ist wenn du niemandem sagst dass sie aus dem Labor kommen.
Clarks Quartier natürlich ist er ist der technische Aufwand im Anschreiben muss eine finanzielle Aufwand im Anschreiben muss wirklich so hoch und es absehbar dass der noch weiter sinkt.
Der technische Aufwand also die Technik um sage jetzt mal lupenrein Diamant zu machen die Technik kommt Gruppe aus den Achtzigern.
Wo also den Achtzigern gab es die ersten Veröffentlichung mit denen saubere wirklich richtig saubere Diamanten gemacht werden konnten,
und der Aufwand an Arbeitskraft und so der stinkt der Herr oder an Rohstoffen der hängt ja extrem stark davon ab.
Wo du das machst hier in Deutschland ist es zu teuer aber in Indien.
Ja geht das.
In Indien geht das.
Doch gemacht.
Ja damit das auch gemacht.
Weil sie Technologie ist jetzt aus dann auch keinen.
Genau die Technologie ist verfügbar generell Diamant zu machen das mit hohen Raten und gut zu machen das ist schon wieder eine etwas andere Geschichte die ist auch verfügbar aber ich würde sagen das kann nicht jeder.
Aber es gibt ein paar Leute die das sehr gut können also ich persönlich habe schon Diamanten in in der Hand gehabt die so von also im Brillantschliff schon fertig geschliffen,
Video von der Fläche her and 15 Stück.
Hatten also der der Teller Base Brillantschliff der unten so spitz und oben der Teller also die.
Klassische dir.
Genau das klassische Diamant Bild und oben dieser dieser Teller war so groß wie ein fünf Cent Stück und die kam aus na also die wahren synthetisch hergestellt.
Und vom Darm also vom vom Aufwand her,
wenn wenn das einmal ordentlich eingerichtet ist und Ohren also der Prozess und so einmal läuft dann läuft da.
Fallen die Steinchen heraus.
Goldesel mäßig.
Ein bisschen ja der Knackpunkt an der Geschichte zumindest am Anfang ist um Diamant schön zu wachsen also das wovon wir immer sprechen also diese diese Schmucksteine was funkelt und so das sind Eiskristalle.
Das heißt der komplette Kristall denona Hunter ist ein einziges Atomgitter das halt schön in alle Richtung periodisch weitergeht und die sogenannten Einkristalle zu wachsen um das richtig zu machen brauchte man zumindest bis vor.
Wann war 20 16 bis vor anderthalb Jahren oder zwei Jahren knapp braucht man dafür einen Diamanten weil Diamant wächst besonders gut auf Diamant.
Der wächst.
Ja ich weiß wir sollen vielleicht mal irgend so eine Richtung zu dem synthetischen und.
Wir sind kurz davor ja ja ich wollte das zumindest mal so die.
Yahoo.
Diesen scope mal abgebildet haben wo sicherlich auch viel Halbwissen nicht nur bei mir vorliegt.
Okay ich denke dass eine einiges Bedarf jetzt sozusagen der der Grundlagen ist es auf ganze Jahren hoch da weiß ich garnicht physikalisches chemisches irgendwie beides Thema.
Wie weit müssen wir denn jetzt sozusagen mal unseren Blick verkleinern ins kleinste gehen um das notwendige Grundwissen aufzubauen zu verstehen was eigentlich ein Diamant so.
Macht und wir auch so entstanden ist ja schon ihr seid alles auf Atomen Ebene was jetzt hier sozusagen verstanden werden muss.
Genau wir könnten mal damit anfangen.
Was ist eigentlich ein Atom.
Genau da stellen wir uns mal ganz dumm.
Ja ich meine da gibt's ja auch nur so Bilder von Sohn.
Ja und das was die meisten der Schule lernen ist auch noch das falsche nein falsch falsch zu sagen dass du irgendwas Falsches ist immer sollte man nicht machen sondern das Bild ist ein sehr einfaches das reicht um viele Sachen zu erklären aber nicht mehr das was aktuell,
so das ist was man eigentlich im Kopf haben sollte wir wir fangen mal folgendermaßen an.
Also im MRT bei mir war Atom und so weiter kein Thema in der Schule.
Ja ist mein viel nicht also kannst du bitte abwählen na dann oder du kannst auch die Mirella.
Wenn es nicht also Waldorfschule wir 80er jahre ganz schlimm.
Ja habe geupdatet vollkommen erwachter die Hochzeit des Atoms.
Ja aber dass die kann da noch nicht so richtig an.
Das Atom es gibt ja verschiedene Modelle nee also früh Wissenschaftlern sich früh gefragt woraus,
wo steht eigentlich die ganze Welt und dann ist man sehr also nun schon die alten Griechen darauf gekommen wenn man irgendwas immer kleiner hat muss man irgendwann bei ihrem was ankommt was nicht mehr klein gehackt werden kann das kleinste Teil unteilbar das ist das Atom.
Und wie dieses Atom aussieht aus dem halt alles aufgebaut ist das ist halt so in der Geschichte der Wissenschaft hat sich das immer,
irgendwann hat man rausgefunden oh dieses Atom ist garnicht nicht,
teilbaren man kann das immer noch mal kannst du noch weiter teilen das Atom diese kleinen Bausteine in Neutronen in.
Protonen und Elektronen sind die kann man auch noch weiter teilen und so weiter und so weiter so so so weit müssen wir gar nicht reingehen Mann,
man hat irgendwann gesagt oder ist uneben Laufe der Geschichte hat irgendwann herausgestellt.
Ikea ein brauchbares Atommodell ist das vom guten Herrn Boris auch das was viele in der Schule vielleicht noch gelernt hat das ist genau das müssen Protonen Neutronen und Elektronen die außenrum fliegen,
da ist das Atom so aufgebaut wie haben den Kern in der Mitte der trägt die ganze Masse.
In die Neutronen und Protonen die Neutronen sind neutral geladen die Protonen sind positiv geladen und genauso bei den neutralen Atomen ist es so genauso viele Protonen wie ein Kern sind hat man Elektronen die außen rumschwirren wieso Planeten,
die Planeten um die Sonne.
Modell das nicht also das erklärt vieles nicht aber keine Menge Sachen erklären und reicht für vieles aus und jetzt ist das so je nachdem wie viele Protonen im Kern sind.
Entscheidet das darüber welches Element wir haben.
Ein Proton im Kern Wasserstoff zwei Protonen im Kern Helium und so weiter und so weiter beim.
Beim Kohlenstoff aus dem der Diamant aufgebaut ist,
und zwar nur aus Kohlenstoff haben wir 6 Protonen im Kern und das heißt wir haben außenrum in allen Schalen wieder außenrum fliegen auch 6 Elektronen die darum fliegen und bei somatom ist es immer relativ wichtig zu wissen,
die Masse steckt im Kern aber die Eigenschaften wie sich ein Element verhält.
Ob es so viel reagiert oder nicht mit anderen das hängt an den Elektronen die außenrum flitzen.
Was heißt wenn in der äußeren Schale irgendwie Platz für Elektronen ist oder da Elektronen zu viel sind oder so dann reagiert das ganz gerne.
Das Element sieht man auch wenn man sich so mal siehst du hast du das Periodensystem der Elemente vor Augen aus dem Chemieunterricht diese bunte Wand mit so.
Ich kenne das ich kann das jetzt nicht auswendig runterbeten und ich wunder mich auch mal wieder dass man immer mal wieder so von so zum Element hört von jemand eigentlich noch nie was gehört hatte sowas gibt's auf das noch an.
Ist ja auch immer ja ja letztes Jahr sind glaube ich zwei oder drei dazukommen japanium z.b. japanium.
Hahnium dass das woraus die schnell Züge gemacht.
Ja genau das gemacht.
Das wächst immer noch wenn immer noch Sachen gefunden also dann halt nach unten in das wenn immer schwerere Sachen Nerven.
Aber gefunden nicht in der Natur gefunden.
Nee nee nee nee nee richtig genau.
Synthetisiert das in irgendeiner Form und stellt fest oder überlebt für ein paar Sekunden bevor Sie verpflichtet.
Genau wenn's denn Sekunden sind aber ja genau irgendwie so Richtung geht das eher so der Rest ist relativ vollständig als man kann durch Ziehen von einem Proton bis ich weiß nicht wo sind wir gerade bei 100 118-119 irgendwo in der Ecke,
kann man in einem durchzählen und jedes Ding immer wenn protona Zukunft hat neuen Namen.
Mit jedem Proton kommt auch mein Elektron mit dazu weil das Atom man sich ja immer neutral geladen ist wenn es nicht.
Ionisiert ist aber lass mir mal vorne also lass mal raus,
und dementsprechend reagiert das ganze auch immer anders wenn man sich mal das Periodensystem der Elemente anguckt dann sieht man ganz rechts immer die Edelgase die haben in diesem bohrschen Atommodell immer außen eine volle Schale mit Elektronen.
Sind voll besetzt und die sind damit glücklich und jedes andere Elemente.
Die reagieren nicht.
Reagieren nicht.
Surfen also ein Physiker Witz ist und Sohn kommt nicht heliumatom in die Bahn nobody react.
Ja genau hatte oder kommt Nordrhein die Bar heute nur für geladene Gäste ne.
Argon und Xenon und sowas.
Genau und Neon und Helium und so weiter das sind das sind Edelgase und die haben halt eine äußere also deren äußere Schale ist komplett mit Elektronen gefüllt und deshalb sind die sehr reaktionsträge,
wie reagieren hat nicht gern alle anderen.
Alles was links davon steht im Periodensystem hat keine vollen Schalen nach vielen Elektronen in den äußeren Hüllen die reagieren ganz gerne,
weil jedes Atom möchte gerne Edelgas sein.
Aber was was heißt denn achso verstehe was warum warum sind sie denn nicht voll also was definiert sinnvoll.
Ja da da kommen in dem bohrschen Atommodell hat man immer Schalen die gefüllt werden auf die erste Schale passen zwei auf die nächste Schale passen warte mal.
436 Bus.
Das ist auf deinem Tattoo nach.
Nein.
Das jetzt auch noch ein Atommodell wo das.
Das mit den Zahlen ist auch nicht das ist an der Stelle auch nicht ganz so gut ist bevor ich ihn wie anfangen was zum bohrschen Atommodell zerkleinere ich lieber das was eigentlich das ist was man heutzutage lernen sollte und zwar das sogenannte Orbitalmodell,
da hat man auch Orbitale und das sind Bereiche in denen sich Elektronen aufhalten.
Diese Bereiche sind z.b. Kugeln also kugelförmig um den Kern rum also ein kugelförmiger Bereich in dem sich ein Elektron aufhält oder es hat auch so hantelförmig.
Lass mich mal Bilder gesehen oder so donutform ich drumrum das sind ganz ganz schräge Form das sind die sogenannten Orbitale das sind Bereiche von Aufenthaltswahrscheinlichkeit and.
Indien Sicherheit das Elektron mit einer gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit aufhält,
diese komischen Form kommen aus der Schrödingergleichung also das ist ein Modell das aus der Quantenmechanik raus fällt ins Orbitalmodell und zwar so dass die Station also die Lösungen der stationären Schrödingergleichung.
Was ist mit der Katze.
Ja genau ist das mit der Katze.
Böhm.
Na ja ja nein nicht wirklich ich glaube wir werden ein bisschen zu sehr ab in die Atommodelle wenn will bleiben wir mal beim Diamant der Diamant besteht aus Kohlenstoff Kohlenstoff hat 6 Elektronen.
Ball auf 6 Protonen hat.
Besteht nur aus Kunststoff.
Diamant besteht nur aus Kohlenstoff also die ideale Form der dialysiert Diamant besteht nur aus Kohlenstoff und dieser Kohlenstoff 6 Elektronen zwei davon sind im.
MRSA vital.
Die sind da glücklich und sind zufrieden und wollen mit den anderen nichts zu tun haben und tun nichts im Wesentlichen und die anderen die anderen vier die noch über bleiben.
Die sind in einem sogenannten Hybrid Orbital also die sind in einer in einer äußeren wahrscheinlichkeits Wolke.
Ein Orbital dass sich aus einem,
s-Orbital und ein P Orbital zusammenbasteln das jetzt akustisch zu erklären wird glaube ich ein bisschen bisschen schräg man kein Versagen dieses Bridge auf ital sieht aus wie eine Pyramide,
Mann sagen also eine Keule geht nach oben und 3 Keulen gehen sie nach unten weg.
Muss man ein Tetraeder hat und in diesem Bereich also in diesem 4 Keulen die sich von der Mitte aus tetraedrisch weg,
also ausstrecken da halten sich irgendwo die Elektronen auf das heißt dieses Kohlenstoffatom wenn es im Diamant ist.
Das ist auch nur wenn es um Diamant ist liegt in einer sogenannten SP3 Hybridisierung vor.
Schöne Worte ne ja super ne sagen geht das Kohlenstoffatom streckt vier Arme aus.
Um sich mit anderen zu verbinden.
Wenn das denn in dem Diamant gebunden ist und diese Form ist halt so tetraedrisch und wenn man davon ganz viele underbut dann hat man den Diamanten.
Das heißt es ist genau diese geometrische Grundstruktur die jetzt so im Wesentlichen auf Wahrscheinlichkeiten auf Aufenthalts Wahrscheinlichkeiten basiert.
Ja die aber sich letzten Endes dann natürlich aber auch manifestieren weil zu sieben wahrscheinlicher dass sie eben in der Struktur sind als irgendeiner anderen das führt dann dazu dass diese.
Atome die Kohlenstoffatome wenn sie denn so aneinandergeraten sich entlang dieser Richtungen auch aneinanderreihen.
Genau wie sie das tun ist wie es bei vielen Materialen ist abhängig vom Druck und von der Temperatur auch.
Wie sie also in welcher Form Sie sich anordnen weil wir wissen ja z.b. das Kohlenstoff ja nichtmals Diamant vorliegen kann sondern auch als Graphit.
Und da ist er ist der Kohlenstoff ein bisschen anders gebunden und bindet an also bildet andere andere Orbital aber jetzt von Diamant.
Aber was heißt er kann nur als Diamant oder ist Graphit wollen dich doch auch noch 1000 anderen.
Ja dein darf man jetzt noch zwei Beispiele also Diamant oder Graphit der kann auch noch vorliegen als,
als am Moor falls irgendwas ne aber wenn man sich das Phasendiagramm von Kohlenstoff anguckt Phasendiagramm ist immer,
Zustand bei einem gewissen Druck und einer gewissen Temperatur dann sind die wesentlichen Formen die man da hat kristallin also kristallinen Form Graphit oder Diamant.
Deshalb gab noch lange Bestrebung aus Graphit Diamant zu machen weil es ja das gleiche Material nur eine andere bindungsstruktur der Atome.
Und wenn wir jetzt beim beim Diamant und diese tetraedrische Struktur angucken dann hat ja jedes jedes Kohlenstoffatom 4 Nachbarn an denen es sich festhält.
Unser das ist das was der Mann zu seine ganzen besonderen Eigenschaften verleiht.
Auch noch mal zu verstehen also bin ich wenn diese tetraederstruktur Susanne Grundeigenschaft von Kohlenstoff ist warum.
Nee das ist es keine Grundeigenschaft von Kohlenstoff Kohlenstoff kann diese Struktur bilden.
Aber nur unter bestimmten Bedingung.
Genau unter bestimmten Bedingungen also.
Was heißt unter anderen Bedingungen gibt es nicht Tetraeder sondern da gibt's andere Ausbreitung Warschau.
Genau unter anderem unter anderen Bedingungen gibt's halt irgendwie sowas sternförmiges was dann so die graphitfarben macht so in die.
Klar.
Das heißt so wie bei also wie sich ein Stoff bindet und wie er auskristallisiert ist immer vom Druck und Temperatur abhängig.
Und das geht jetzt nicht nur für ein Kohlenstoff sein für alles.
Das gibt mal 1 Das.
Sätzlich Temperatur ist wichtig.
Richtig das gilt auch für für Eisen z.b. man lernt auch das lämmer noch Maschinenbau das eisen-kohlenstoff-diagramm Eisen kann auch in verschiedenen Formen auskristallisieren.
Also da gibt's so die Standard die Standard Kristallgitter die man kennt sind einfach kubisch.
Das ist so im Grunde Würfel wo auf jeder Ecke des Würfels einen Atom sitzt.
Wann gibt es so kubisch raumzentriert da hat man auch auf jeder Ecke ein Atom sitzen und noch eins in der Mitte des Würfels und dann gibt es kubisch flächenzentriert da hat man auch auf jeder Ecke einen sitzen.
Und auf jeder Mittelalter auf jedem Mittelpunkt der Seitenflächen.
Das sind verschiedene Zustandsform von Eisen.
Nervende versch.
Kohlenstoff in Kombination.
Von eigentlich fast allem also das was Grundlegendes ne Festkörperphysik alles was irgendwie ein Kristallstruktur vorlieb hat halt eine dieser dieser Strukturen.
Darunter zu verstehen das noch mal einen Begriff auch noch mal ein bisschen genauer rausnehmen nämlich Kristallen hat er das schon tausendmal gesagt was meine Teil kennt man so gemeinhin nur außen.
Haushaltsladen.
Ja genau genau.
So oder oder aus dem aus der Esoterik Bude im Prenzlauer Berg so was bezeichnet Kristall in dem Kontext.
Tallis eigentlichen mathematisch physikalischer Begriff und zwar ist das eine Struktur die sich periodisch über also in alle Raumrichtungen unendlich fortsetzen,
Suppenkaspar.
Was heißt wenn ich wenn ich mir ein Gitter vorstelle na das aus aus Würfeln besteht ganz viele Würfel und ich habe wie gesagt mal auf jeder Ecke davon ein ein Atom packe dann habe ich ja einen raumgitter,
darf ich in alle Richtungen unendlich im Grunde fortsetzen lässt und das nennt man einen Kristall.
In Bezug auf Atome oder gibt es diesen Begriff auch unabhängig von Atomen.
Wie du schon sagst dann wird halt auch ne für Gläser benutzt was er eigentlich falsches weil Glas ist kein Kristall zumindest nicht physikalisch Zeiten also,
Kristall zusagen und Physiker man mit Kristall was anderes als jemand der im Haushaltswarenladen Arbeit.
Ja das dachte ich mir schon.
Genau aber Kristall ist eigentlich immer das was was ich halt,
Periode Sport setzt manchmal meinen die Leute auch das gleiche ohne es zu merken also wenn wenn ich jetzt von einem Diamant Kristall rede dann redet auch jemand also und jemand anders auch von einem Diamant Kristallgitter meinen wir das gleiche ich meine physikalisch er meint das als Schmuckstein,
aber trotzdem beides richtig es ist ein Kristall wohin wenn wir von einem Glas reden dann ist das was ich sage dass es ein.
Glas und der andere sagt das ist ein Kristallglas dann ist Kristallglas falsch weil das macht keinen Sinn es sei denn das Glas ist auf einem Kristall geschliffen.
Aber wann kommt diese Gitterstruktur zum zum Tragen ist das etwas was natürlich.
Wohin alles strebt oder ist das ein Ausnahmezustand der nur unter bestimmten Bedingungen oder hängt das vom Material ab.
Da finde ich würde sagen dass das hängt vom Material ab und es ist auch wieder etwas das halt also wo wohin.
Ja wo wohin Materialien Streben würde ich sagen wenn man sie in die richtigen Bedingungen setzt.
Man kennt das ja vielleicht von denen jetzt nämlich ein ganz so gutes Beispiel diese Taschenwärmer.
Wenn man wenn man die knickt entsteht da ja auch so dann wächst ja auch was Einkristall drin und da ist es auch so das Material ist vorher flüssig dann wird kurz Energie zugegeben durch das Knicken.
Und dann wechselt das in einen energetisch günstigeren Zustand und zwar in eine Kristallstruktur,
mit dem kleinen Schubs hat also dieser keine Schubs hat halt gereicht um dem genug Energie zu geben damit es seinen Zustand ändern kann in die energetische günstigere Form des Kristalls.
Ball hat geordnet ist energetisch günstiger deshalb gibt es Werbung ab.
Energiesatz an Überschuss.
Energieüberschuss da und dafür dass Wärme abgegeben deshalb macht zum Brottaschen warm und bei.
Bei Diamant oder generell bei Kristallen und doch so wenn dieses Kristallgitter das ja nicht immer perfekt,
nativo kaputt ist z.b. irgendwie Versetzungen drin sind oder was abgebrochen ist sagen wir mal oder irgendwo patum Befehlen wenn Kratzer drin ist,
wenn man das in die richtigen also auf die richtige Temperatur bringt und den richtigen Druck dann teilen also dann heilen solche Kratzer aus.
Weil dann die Atome anfangen im Gitter zu wandern und wieder an Zustand einnehmen der halt energetisch am günstigsten ist.
Also das ist schon was wo wenn es einmal in dieser die Richtung geht Materialien hin streben.
Okay und dafür brauchen sie aber einen Anstoß und das ist in der Regel so etwas wie Druck oder Hitze oder beides.
Nee ist es braucht kein Anstoß sondern es muss in dieser Umgebung in dieser Situation der energetisch günstiger Zustand sein.
Also bei wenn man sich mal Kohlenstoff anguckt wenn man Kohlenstoff jetzt sowie in der Erde also in diesem Vulkangestein unten unter hohen Druck und hohe Temperaturen bringt dann ist der Diamant also die Diamantstruktur energetisch günstiger,
als die Graphit Struktur und deshalb geht der Kohlenstoff dann in die Diamantstruktur.
Warum ist die energetisch günstiger.
Das ist unter diesen Bedingungen halt so.
Ja also dass ich das irgendwie verstehen also es ist es ist ja mehr so eine Fluchtbewegung sozusagen also bitte der der Stoff versucht immer im in einem idealen Zustand zu sein.
Indem in genau in dem Zustand der unter diesen Bedingungen energetisch günstig ist in der Bindung und so.
Ja also wie sich die Elektronen letzten und die Atome über ihre Elektronen miteinander verbinden.
Warum sollen sie nicht immer kristallinen sein weil klingt ja irgendwie so wie du wieder tolle Sache ja alles gerade ausgerichtet alles passt aneinander klingt ja nach sowieso einen idealen Urzustand in Indien alles Streben wollen würde.
Weil nicht alles was um also weil nicht alles kristallin ist was uns z.b. umgibt.
Wenn du wenn jetzt mal Spiel mal einen Kristall nimmst und den verformt dann ist er nicht mehr kristallin.
Alleine durch Bewegung durch Beschläge durch Thermo thermodynamische Fluktuation einfach hast du halt Bereiche die dann nicht mehr kristallinen sind und so entstehen dann irgendwann auch ein Mord für Sachen.
Also amorf heißt nicht.
Amorph heißt nicht kristallin also amorph heißt weder LAN noch Fernordnung.
Okay.
Ich würde sagen die mich vertan das hält sich so die Waage also,
selten sind Einkristalle das Sachen wirklich nur aus einem Teil bestehen weil wenn du jetzt so ein Stück Metall anguckst dass du bei dir trägst deinen Schlüssel z.b.
der ist schon kristallin also wenn man da hin guckt die das Eisen das liegt schon kristallin vor nicht am Morgen davor,
aber es ist kein Eingriff Teil dein Schlüssel besteht nicht aus einem einzigen ein Unfall sondern auf tausenden wenn man den an schleift und mal Annett und sich unter Mikroskop angucken dann sieht man ganz viele kleine Körner jedes Korn für sich,
ist kristallin das ganze Ding insgesamt aber polykristallin besteht aus tausenden kleinen Kristallen also Metalle kann man sagen mit Halle sind im Allgemeinen kristallin.
Kunst.
Okay für mich jetzt auch schon meine Erkenntnis überhaupt erstmal so so die die die Dämlichkeit von Alben überhaupt erstmal in diese zwei Kategorien einzuteilen also entweder ist etwas liegt irgendwie kristalin phore Sozialstruktur oder nicht.
So was anderes gibt's nicht.
Dann machst du einfach auf ja.
Oh Gott aber es taucht ist auch diese einfache unter.
Das Dach kann das kann man machen das kann man machen.
Ich bin mir sicher dass da noch verschiedene Übergangs und.
Kosice und so weiter ne also du du hast ja auch du hast ja auch Sachen die nicht nur aus einem Element bestehen sondern aus mehreren die können auch wieder kristallin sein können aber auch amorph sein.
Komme wieder zurück zum Diamant also der Diamant ist Kohlenstoff der.
In einer bestimmten kristallinen Form vorliegt.
Denn einer bestimmt kristallinen Form vorliegt weil er sich an einem Ort befand wo die richtigen Bedingungen geherrscht haben um genau diese Form herzustellen und da ist es wahrscheinlich warm gewesen oder herrscht ein Überdruck oder beides.
Da war es höchstwahrscheinlich warm und es hat verdammt ohrdruck geherrscht.
Also beides ist sozusagen zuträglich oder beides ist erforderlich.
Beides ist erforderlich unzuträglich es ist es ist so die diamantendiebe aus Minen holen.
Die sind genauso also diese mit sehr sehr sehr hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit genau so entstanden hoher Druck hohe Temperatur und genauso hat man auf die ersten synthetischen Diamanten gemacht in großen riesigen pressen so hydraulisch pressen.
Bei hoher Temperatur mit viel Druck lange Zeit.
Man hat aber dann herausgefunden oder Forchheim herausgefunden dass das nicht die einzige Möglichkeit ist,
diamants machen sondern man kann Diamanten auch im Unterdruck machen was auch eine frage dich häufig gestellt, du machst sind Diamanten so mit viel Druck und so eine war ich nie mit Unterdruck,
man kann Diamanten und das ist die Variante wie man saubere Diamanten macht in einer sogenannten chemischen gasphasenabscheidung machen,
also im Unterdruck.
Mit ganz ganz wenig Druck weil es dort im Phasendiagramm also ne wieder dieses Phasendiagramm dass uns beschreibt an unter welchen Bedingungen welche Kristallstruktur oder nicht.
Günstig ist auf der einen Achse Temperatur auf der anderen Druck.
Kann man ganz großen Bereich des Diamant bei viel Druck und viel Temperatur es gibt aber noch einen ganz kleinen Bereich unten links.
Viel Temperatur sage ich mal und ganz ganz wenig Druck der auch günstig für Diamant ist.
Und da warum der genau günstig für Diamant ist da muss man auch sehr weit für ausholen.
Weil diese in dieser selben kombinationsmatrix aus Temperatur und Druck fällt auch irgendwo Graphit an Rhein.
Fotografiert ein rein da fällt auch irgendwann gar nicht kristallin also irgendwie amorph kommt davon auch vor und das gibt es eigentlich also ein Phasendiagramm gibt eigentlich für jedes Element.
Und das ist immer so ein zweidimensionales Ding mit Druck und Temperatur oder gucke.
Ja das gibt's ja Wasser z.b. was hast du schönes Beispiel Wasser ist halt bei bei 0 Grad fängt an fest zu werden und bildet Eiskristalle wenn man heiser macht wird immer ein flüssigmalz noch heißer macht Dampf das irgendwann weg.
Seidemann erhöht den Druck man kann Wasser ja auch über 100 Grad heizen.
Wenn man unter Druck setzt.
Wenn man unter Druck setzt genau.
Bzw unter Unterdruck kocht sein halt früher.
Genauer unter Druck kocht früher genau und das ist genau die ist Phasendiagramm Wasser für Wasser kennen ist im Grunde für Kohlenstoff genau das gleiche nur Daelim Zeit unterschiedliche Kristallform ein und ihrem Mann Dampf bauchweg und so.
Halte die mit Phasendiagramm anfangen ja.
Möbel Zimmermann versteht die Dinger ja auch nur wenn man sie mal richtig erklärt ich wollte dir dabei helfen auch.
Ja danke.
Diamant besser zu verstehen.
Der arbeitet doch da gibt's noch so einiges zu herauszufinden aber bei Heirat dabei so ein bisschen mein Mann,
Erkenntnisse zu sagen es ist ganz Nase der Diamant will unter den richtigen Bedingung machen du sagst die natürlich gefundenen Diamanten Naturdiamanten die.
Diesen wahrscheinlich einfach hoher Druck hohe Temperatur aber man hat dann eben durch die Erforschung dieser Phänomen und unter anderem durch Betrachtung dieser Phasendiagramm oder vielleicht waren sie auch nur ein Ergebnis dessen auf jeden Fall,
gibt es auch andere.
Zustands Kombinationen die auch dazu führen dass der Kohlenstoff sich gerne maximal kristallin eben in dieser Diamantstruktur ausrichten will das hat ja gesagt kraftfit ist auch ne.
Auch eine kristalline Struktur des selben materials was ist denn dann anders.
Da haben wir nicht diese SP3 Hybridisierung.
Ja die was heißt.
Diese SPD Überdosierung heißt dass sich die die äußeren vier Elektronen halt in diesem Tetraeder in diese Tetraeder riecht.
Sondern dass es eine andere Richtung.
Genau ist eine andere Richtung und zwar was zweidimensionales war sehr planares da gehen die gehen die äußeren Elektronen halt solche Bindung ein dass du diese Honigwaben bilden.
Kennt eine Einzel Lage graffit ist ja auch dieses berühmte richtig zu draffehn.
Und diese einzelnen Graffin Laden im Graphit die aufeinander liegen die liegen nur so leicht versetzt aufeinander,
diesen zwischen also innerhalb der Ebene des Kaffees haben die sehr ähnliche Strukturen wie Diamant das ist auch sehr sehr hart und selber fest aber die einzelnen Lagen untereinander sind nur sehr lose miteinander verbunden und deshalb ist Graphit zu weich.
Bei die Lagen übereinander Abscheren.
Ja und Graphit kommt aber auch sozusagen natürlich vor also da wo man nach Diamanten schreibt dann kann es auch genauso gut sein dass man irgendwie viel Traffic rausholt.
Kann man auch genauso guten Graphit irgendwo rausholen kann auch passieren.
Verstehe es wird das schon alles viel klarer.
Könnten genauso ist man ja auch herangegangen die ersten synthetischen Diamanten zu machen Mann nimmt sich Graphit und versucht dieses Grafit halt in die Umstände zu bringen dass Diamant die günstigere Variante wäre.
Hör auf damit Druck und Temperatur.
Genau mitdrucken Temperatur also mein Mann setzt den graffit unter massiven Druck und Heiz den richtig schön hoch.
Warum nimmt man als Graffiti, nein Prinzip Kohlenstoff in jeder beliebigen Form von dem Alter liegt es schon mal rein vor oder wir ja.
Genau das schon mal sauber ja du kannst auch einfach du kannst einfach Graphitpulver irgendwas Hauptsache Kohlenstoff ne du.
Du musst den nur möglich sauber haben das halt nichts anderes drinne und den musst du halt heizen möglich auf so 2008 ein paar Gigapascal Druck das ist ordentlich.
Ja wie viele Fahnen sind das.
Viele Männer sind wirklich sehr sehr viele also das ist das ist sehr sehr hoher Druck für die Erfindung der pressen die dazu nötig sind ganz Nobelpreis.
Also das ist nicht ohne sowas also man simuliert ja die Zustände im Inneren der Erde quasi also.
Ja ja ist schon in Menge.
Das ist tatsächlich ne Menge Mann Mann nimmt sich halt man nimmt sich möglichst sauberen Kohlenstoff 25 enfants album Graphit,
das in eine Presse heizt das auf und bringt es ein Phasendiagramm in einem Bereich wo Diamant halt günstiger ist im Idealfall packt man noch ein winzig kleinen Diamanten mit da rein,
damit man einen Nukleation Skyrim hat also.
Ein ein Diamant der halt von dem aus die Umstrukturierung des Kohlenstoff quasi ausgeht und.
Das weiter wächst so ähnlich wie die wie das Knicken bei denen Handwärmern.
Ja genau.
Das ist ein Begriff der mich auch mal ein bisschen verwirrt hat das Kristalle wachsen jetzt hat er ja sozusagen unter wachsen das ist so ein unfassbar organischer Begriff die man jetzt überall sieht so und.
Wie muss man sich da also was wächst da also Wackel wachsen ist jetzt quasi nur ein Synonym für die sich selbst fortsetzen kristalline Ausrichtung der.
Atoma oder.
Im Grunde ja du hast ja du hast ja den Diamant Kristall der aus SP3 Hybridisierung Kohlenstoff besteht der diese genau ist ein Tetraeder also der in die tetraedrisch in Richtung sein Elektronen raus.
Wie heißen die wie hieß der noch mal diese der jobs-amazon.de früher so eine Trinkhalle diese Nummer seinen Strohhalm diese Päckchen genau wie heißt es gesund ist oder was war das.
Was du mir ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ja sowieso was alles war immer so schön Tetraeder kann ich das ja schön vorstellen.
Ja also du hast halt diese Tetraeder Form und die halt in alle Richtungen periodisch fortgesetzt aber das ist ein idealer Kristall natürlich Kristall hat halt irgendwo auch ein Ende.
Er hat halt auf das heißt diese diese.
Ja diese gebunden SP3 überdosieren Kohlenstoffatome die kommen irgendwann ein Ende und da ist irgendwas anderes.
Und dieses Ende bedeutet ja das da irgendwo,
Elektron wo in die Oberfläche also so nach oben ragen weil die keinen Bindungspartner mehr haben da wo der Kristall aufhört und hast du Oberflächenphysik da passiert wieder ganz viel diese dingeling bonds nennt man die also,
ungesättigte Bindungen die nach oben zeigen die verbinden sich dann gerne mal also die die binden Hals miteinander.
Und Schließen Kristall an dieser Stelle ab wenn man jetzt aber die richtigen Bedingungen schafft und dann noch andere Kohlenstoff ist dann kann er sich ja da an lagern und das Gitter fortsetzen und genauso wechseln Diamant.
Das heißt wenn man den jetzt synthetisch herstellt weil du hast jetzt vorhin deswegen mich alles noch mal drauf gekommen was wärst du es genannt wenn du sagen da so ein Diamant so quasi als Quelle von allem.
Perso nucleation skymm.
Enukleation Skyrim das sein dass ein Wort ganz toll.
Schönes Wort oder solche Worte hätte man in der vierten Klasse gerne bei hangman kant.
Ja sicherlich jetzt auch für was ich jetzt eigentlich so Kreuzworträtsel für Physiker so ja oder so so so.
Rebel.
Ja genau so so so Physiker Scrabble wo man irgendwie mit solchen Begriffen kommen kann das Wetter noch mal eine Erfindung.
Klauen schönen Tag für Chemiker organische Verbindungen die sind ja auch gerne mal so richtig lachen.
Ja so als Puzzle irgendwie.
Bitte die Neuauflage von wir bauen uns ein Atomkraftwerk wie soll man so zeigt nicht richtige Kombination gefunden hat dann.
Fing alles an zu brennen so dann heißt innen und Prozesse synthetische Herstellung eines Diamanten.
Ja und jetzt verschiedene Varianten gibt.
Ja aber genauso diese Hochdruck Niederdruck Variante die 2007 kleinen Bereich ist aber die man weniger Aufwand betreiben kann weil wenn ich mit diese ganze Elefanten Presse braucht.
Besser kontrollierbar.
Und besser kontrollierbar ist aber viel Temperatur unter Umständen oder Meer Temperatur weiß ich.
Nicht gleich großen Ordnung.
Ah okay gut also in diesem Bereich das ja das was man dazu sagen wenn man synthetischen was du auch im Wesentlichen gemacht hast.
So und kann man das so sagen reicht es wenn ich da so etwas Grafit nehmen und dann funktioniert es auch oder warum brauche ich jetzt meinen.
Die Aktion.
Den nimmst du in den present ganz gerne du kannst auch los muss nicht unbedingt Diamant sein es gibt auch andere andere Kristalle die ähnliche Struktur haben also,
die quasi so ein bisschen wie ein Katalysator wirken und das Atom Wachstum dann anregen in den pressen.
Das was ich aber gemacht habe also diese diese Niederdruck sind hier ist noch meine anderen eigentlich eine komplett andere Geschichte da nimmst du dämlich,
da gibt's zwei Varianten homo Epitaxie und hetro Epitaxie homoeopathy bedeutet du lässt einen Diamant Kristall weiterwachsen.
Hydro RP Taxi bedeutet nimmt einen fremd Kristall und lässt darauf einen Diamanten wachsen.
Also fremd Kristall im Sinne von nicht Kohlenstoff.
Nicht Diamant ja aber nicht Kohlenstoff und wieso nicht noch genau.
Das was somit ich mich viel Geschichte beschäftigt habe es halt die homo App Taxi du nimmst einen Diamant Kristall bringst den in deinen Prozess in dieser Niederdruck Synthese und lässt den dort weiter wachsen.
Niederdruck Synthese kann verschiedene wieder verschiedene Unterarten das was man macht wenn man sehr saubere Diamanten machen möchte ist eine Plasma CVD einen Plasma also eine chemical vapour deposition,
Plasma Unterstützung.
Chemische Dampf Disposition.
Genau also die chemische gasphasenabscheidung übersetzen uns glaube ich dann ja das passiert folgendermaßen du nimmst deinen Kristall wachsen in einer Anlage.
Und diese Anlage bei dieser Anlage Pumps als allererstes mal die Luft raus weil du bist ja keine Luft drin haben.
Vakuumtechnik kann das schon.
Da hatten wir das mit der Waffentechnik und hier sauberer der Kristall am Ende sein soll den du da wachsen möchtest desto besser solltest du da die Luft raus bekommen.
Deshalb ist Vakuumtechnik bei dem was ich gemacht habe recht wichtiger Bestandteil weil ich halt sehr sehr saubere Diamanten gemacht habe.
Alles was potenzieller nicht raus gepumpt wird landet am Ende da drin.
Genau kann halt mit einer gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit dadrin landen.
Wie wie wie viel Akku mir Test das dann.
Die Anlage die ich gebaut habe hatte einen basisdruck von im Bereich von 10 hoch -9 Milly heißt 0,000.
Mainova.
Wenig sehr wenig so als Faustregel für das nennt man freie Weglänge also wie weit ist es bis zu einem nächsten Atom,
also bis zwei Atome aufeinanderstoßen sollst Faustregel kann man der Vakuumtechnik sagen bei 10 hoch -3 Millibar.
Hast du sechs Zentimeter frei Weglänge Erzählung - 4 sind 60 cm.
Und bei 10 hoch also bei 10 hoch -9.
Das Paul hat Meter kein Atom.
Hast du ganz ganz viel Platz bist du das nächste Atom trifft da ist die frei Weglänge aber durch die durch die Abmessung der Anlage schlicht und einfach beschränkt weil das nächste Atom triffst du an der Wand.
Ja okay aber das heißt das ist dann schon wirklich richtig leer.
Wetter ist ja das ist schon sehr leert man kann noch deutlich niedriger gehen wenn man sich irgendwo den LHC oder so anguckt wo die halt da Teilchenbeschleuniger durch die Gegend Hermann dass man soweit sie noch - 12 ml oder 10 - 13 sogar so da.
Da geht noch was.
Logo diese die haben ja aber auch die Strecke da wo Sie es brauchen ne.
Ja also da da da geht tatsächlich noch einiges 10 hoch -9 ist aber.
Also ist kein Problem ist Standard heutzutage,
da wird bei Vakuumtechnik sehr interessant weil du später andere Arten von Pumpen gebrauchen kann zwar so eine Luftpumpe somit Kompression und irgendwie durch ein Ventil raus und verdrängen und so funktioniert in dem Bereich nicht mehr.
Da brauchst du andere da da fängst du an getterpumpe noch so die verbliebenen Atome irgendwo ionisiert beschleunigt und irgendwo im plantillas also kann beliebig kompliziert werden diese 10 hoch -9 Millibar ist,
prinzipiell nicht besonders dolle ist aber für diese Anlage schon sehr gut weil die,
konstruktionsbedingt eine bestimmte Art von Dichtungen nicht benutzen kann die man da eigentlich für solche tiefen drücke bräuchte.
Damit das ganze auch dicht hält.
Ja damit der halt nichts von außen reinkommt,
genau die die Anlage die ich gebaut habe mit der man solche Diamanten macht die benutzt inverse gehen wir noch mal ganz also geh mal zurück wie das im Unterdruck funktioniert du nimmst dir deinen.
Nimmst einen Kristall wachsen in die Anlage dann kommst du alles raus was du nicht haben willst und dann kommst du die Garage rein die du haben willst und die die du brauchst um Diamant im Alten Bug um wachsen zu lassen ist Methan.
Methan ist der Kohlenstoff Lieferant Methan ist CH4 als ein Kohlenstoff 4 Wasserstoffatome.
Und Wasserstoff noch zusätzlich den brauchst du auch dann hast du deinen Behälter da liegt der Diamant drin einfach gemacht.
Und du lässt Methan und Wasserstoff da rein in den Behälter noch aber immer noch im Unterdruck also immer noch so also weniger als wir hier in unserer Atmosphäre so um uns rum haben bei einem Druck von 100-200 Millibar.
Super schönes explosive Angelegenheit an dich.
Ist ja kein Sauerstoff dabei da also da da verbrennt nichts also exclusiv w-exclusiv jetzt wenn du lecker und der Luft reinkommt dann.
Neapel.
Ja genau du hast du 200 ml mit einem also Unterdruck immernoch aber 200 Millibar Wasserstoff und Methan das da drin ist und so über deinem Diamant irgendwo rum wabert.
Dann nimmst du dir einen mikrowellengenerator mit zu 1,5 Kilowatt Leistung und hemmersmeier Mikrowelle nahrain.
In dieser Anlage dann passiert folgendes Mikrowellen sind ja nichts anderes als ein sich schnell ändern das elektromagnetisches Feld mit 2,4 5 Gigahertz.
Uns gefällt es sehr stark und das macht jetzt mit den mit den Molekülen also mit dem CH4 folgendes das reichstes auseinander.
Uns auch beim Wasserstoff das H2 wird auch auseinandergerissen und dann steht atomarer Wasserstoff.
Aus den USA.
Bin auf einem h und genau auf einem der braucht ja so in der Natur nicht vor da hat man immer H2.
Und dieser Wasserstoff den man hat und das Methan und die ganzen radikale die da da entstehen dadurch die absorbieren die Energie der Mikrowellen.
Werden habe ich angeregt und verlieren ihre Elekta den werden die Elektronen weggerissen sozusagen.
Die Elektronen folgendem elektromagnetischen Feld also der der fällt Schwankung hoch runter hoch runter z.b. jetzt ganz ganz simpel ausgedrückt weil die Elektronen sehr leicht sind die haben kaum Masse der mir folgende was die Masse liegt immer im Kern.
Die Elektronen bewegen sich sehr sehr schnell folgendem Feld werden ihren Atomen entrissen und die atomrümpfe also die,
Kerne im Grunde die können sich nicht so schnell bewegen die bleiben eher so an Ort und Stelle die werden zwar auch bewegt aber die bringen sich nicht so schnell dadurch entsteht ein Plasma.
Also man.
Also das ist.
Was ist Plasma.
Erstmal ist wenn die Elektronen von ihrem Kern irgendwie.
Ja
Weggeschickt.
Genau also Plasma ist ein stark ionisiertes Gas also Atome denen die Elektronen weggerissen werden genau in diesem Plasma.
Das dann auch zu wen ist weil das leuchtet das ist dann du hast deinen Diamant Kristall und dadrüber leuchtet ein großer Ball dass das Plasma,
in diesem Plasma hast du jetzt atomaren Wasserstoff du hast verschiedenste ch radikale also ohne Kohlenstoff nur mit noch einem Wasserstoff dran welche mit noch zwei Wasserstoff dran.
Weil die.
Die auch auseinander geworden sind genau du halt atomaren Wasserstoff und verschiedenste ch radikale oder C also Kohlenstoff der darum fliegt und unten hast du jetzt diesen kleinen Diamant der davon komplett unbeeindruckt ist erstmal.
Dieser Diamant hat ja wie gesagt was ich vorhin sagte diese Denklingen Bonns also diese Bindung dir so in die Luft streckt die aber mit sich selbst binden weil er kein anderer benutzt Partner da ist.
So quasi so seine Antennen mit irgendwie hier hier hier hier könnte ihre Werbung.
Hier könnte ihre Tormann lagern.
Aber die ist stecken nicht einfach die Luft sondern die halten sich halt selbst fest weil Bindung wollen in die haben nichts anderes wollen aber gesättigt sein also halten sich gegenseitig fest.
Jetzt kommt von atomarer Wasserstoff daher.
Der See reaktives weil dem fehlt ja ein Elektron der will unbedingt Helium sein also der will die gleiche Konfession haben die Helium als er will mehr Elektronen haben.
Revitana das Diamant der hat Elektronen oben dann nehme ich mir doch mal eins.
Wie geht dann hin und lagert sich einen Diamant an das heißt nach sehr sehr schneller Zeit ist die Oberfläche mit mit Wasserstoff terminiert das heißt an jedem an jedem denken Bond hängt Hals und Wasserstoffatomen dran.
Dann kommt aber gelegentlich mal das Jahr einen also sehr dynamisch was passiert als der schneller Prozessor kommt gelegentlich ein anderer atomarer Wasserstoff vorbei.
Sieht auch da ist auch Wasserstoff und bindet wieder an den Wasserstoff und dann ist die Bindung zwischen Wasserstoff und Wasserstoff höher als die zwischen Wasserstoff und dem.
Diamant, das heißt es kommen immer Elektro also es kommen immer Wasserstoffatome gehen aber auch wieder weg.
Alter.
Noch als 1:30 Uhr dann wieder weg wenn wieder zerrissen der ganze Scheiß fängt wieder von vorne an das heißt den Diamanten ordentlich auf.
Weil jedesmal Energie übertragen wird dabei bei dem blinden und.
Na ja also es wird jetzt garnicht extern noch irgendwie Wärme zugeführt sondern die entsteht einfach nur aus dieser ganzen chaotischen Aktivität der ganzen Atome.
Da die Wärme im Kristall entsteht im Wesentlichen durch die Anlagerung des Wasserstoff und es wieder weggehen also dieses wasserstoffplasma.
Das also das Plasma oben steht ja zum Großteil aus Wasserstoff heizt den Diamant unglaublich auf und zwar locker auf 1000 Grad.
Man muss den sogar wenn man in die richtigen also man im Phasendiagramm an der richtigen Stelle landen möchte muss man den Diamant Zucker kühlen damit er nicht zu heiß wird.
Wie eigentlich Energie kommt durch diese Mikrowellenstrahlung mit dir das ganze.
Energie kommt durch die Mikrowellen die man fahrenheit.
Jetzt hatten wir die Variante dass sich wasserstoffanlage hat an den Diamant aber anstatt des Wasserstoffs kann sich ja auch Sonnen ch radikal anlagern also im Grunde 1c also ein Kohlenstoff.
Unser Kohlenstoff der Macht eine andere Bindung als der Wasserstoff der Macht direkt diese diese Hybrid,
diese Doppelbindung ist eine kovalente Bindung der einen also Didi der der wächst im Grunde das Kristallgitter des Diamant II.
Also das ist jetzt kovalent heißt weil es derselbe Stoff ist weiß CS.
Quallen Quallen als kovalente Bindung bezeichnet man das wenn wenn Atome keine Elektronen austauschen.
Sondern nie mehr als ganz ganz einfaches Beispiel mal den Wasserstoff wer mir gesagt Wasserstoff an sich atomarer Wasserstoff ist ein Proton mit einem Elektron außenrum.
Der taucht aber in der Natur immer als H2 auf.
Weil zwei Wasserstoffatome dann zusammen kommen und die teilen sich ihre beiden Elektronen die halten sich irgendwo zwischen den Beinen hauptsächlich auf.
Weil dann beide Wasserstoffatome zwei Elektronen haben und damit Helium Konfiguration erreicht haben sozusagen also ein Edelgas eine Edelgaskonfiguration.
Weil die Atome sind wollen wollen ja eigentlich alle wenn sie später mal groß sind weil sie alle Angelika.
Die wollen alle ein Edelgas sein und jedes Wasserstoffatom also atomarer Wasserstoff hat aber nur ein Elektron will aber zwei haben,
wenn man jemanden das nicht wegnehmen kann dann teilt man halt.
Teilen das nennt man eine kovalente Bindung und das macht Diamant auch bei diese tetraedrische Bindung von Diamant das sind alles kovalente Bindungen und die sind sehr sehr stark.
Weil auch die wollen gerne Edelgas sein und das nächste was an der Edelgaskonfiguration kommt es diese starke Bindung.
Das ist wenn man sich jetzt muss ich mal ganz kurz gucken was da an der richtigen Stelle im Periodensystem steht wenn man sie anguckt dem Kohlenstoff damit der bei Neon landet das wäre das nächste Edelgas immer nach also nach oben hin fehlendem vier Elektronen.
Und der machte diese vier Bindungen und teilt mit den anderen und hat dann im Grunde Edelgaskonfiguration.
Na verstehe okay das heißt dieses ganze zerschmetterte Methan in dieser Plasma Suppe greift sich jetzt die freigewordenen Oberflächen Punkte des existierenden Diamant.
Die dadurch frei geworden sind das kurz vorher so wild gewordenes Wasserstoffatom,
komm schnell da mal angedockt ist dann aber irgendwie oder ich gehe dann doch lieber mit dem was ich am besten kenne da ist noch so ein anderes,
cooles Wasserstoffatom machte den Weg frei der Diamant ist in dem Moment sozusagen dann ist halt dieser Banking Bond also diese offenstehende Außenkante quasi das Diamant ist in dem Moment verfügbar und.
Dann doch das Adresse Kohlenstoff könnte jetzt solange der Diamant so an den Enden mit sich selber verbunden ist wird diese Reaktion Sony.
Doch das doch das würde auch gehen aber dass er so mit sich Selbst verbunden ist ist auch nicht so häufig du hast mir nur Diamant so in der Hand hast ist die Oberfläche häufig mit irgendwas terminiert.
Also das da hängt dann was also entweder das mit sich selbst,
warum spielt mit sich selbst oder da hängt halt Wasserstoff auf der Oberfläche oder Sauerstoff oder irgendwas aber diese atomarer Wasserstoff da auf dem Platz mal kommt der nimmt egal was da an der Oberfläche ist der nimmt das weg erstmal so dass da der blanke,
Kohlenstoff ist und der andere Kohlenstoff dann da dran.
Asus schafft einfach da an der Stelle die notwendige Reaktion Freude und durch diesen Gesamtenergie Austausch der Stadt findet befindet sich das ganze dann auch noch in der richtigen Temperatur sodass der Kohlenstoff sagt okay.
Jetzt ist mal richtig Zeit für kristallines abfeiern.
An an dieser an dieser Oberfläche hat man dann also das ist kein,
thermisches Gleichgewicht wie man es in den pressen hat in der present versucht man thermisch an den Punkt zu kommen wo das dann halt im Gleichgewicht ist und dadurch dass das so viel passiert also so viel hin hämmert und sich bewegen sich auch schnell die Teilchen im,
Plasma.
Fluktuiert und dann trifft auch immer mal wieder die richtige Temperatur.
Hat man eine da hat man eine Therme und also hat man eine einen Bereich im Phasendiagramm der ist thermodynamisch zwar nicht im Gleichgewicht aber dort ist trotzdem Diamant in diesem thermischen Ungleichgewicht günstig als Strukturen deshalb Wechsler der Diamant weiter,
das ist die sehr dass es die vereinfachte Variante aber sowieso Moment also da kommt noch ein bisschen was zu so soweit ist aber klar oder.
Ja ich glaube das also ich habe das jetzt für mich ganz erfasst also frag mich gerade ob es noch not tut irgendwas noch mal zusammenzufassen ich hätte jetzt nur schnell die Frage gehabt wie schnell muss man sich diesen Prozess,
vorstellen also wenn man sich da jetzt so zehn minuten daneben stehe wie viele Lagen,
Kohlenstoffatome sind dann so in in der Lage sich da drauf zu packen.
Dauert das ganz lange muss ich da wochenlang daneben sitzen bisher überhaupt was geschehen ist oder ist so zehn minuten später auf einmal auf 5 cm Diamant.
Dass das nicht dass das hängt natürlich auch wieder das Schema kann in der Wissenschaft immer sagen kommt drauf an.
Mssfix um ihre Sachen ab aber du kannst sagen wenn du wenn du hur,
wenn du hur hohe Wachstumsraten fährst also wenn du ein Cop prozesshafte dahingehend optimiert ist von dir dass er möglichst schnell wächst also möglichst schnell viel Diamant macht.
In halbwegs akzeptabler Qualität dann bist du so bei irgendwas zwischen 30 und 50 Mikrometer pro Stunde.
Na bist du schon schnell.
Also wenn du so einen wenn es um Zentimeter mal Zentimeter mal Zentimeter Diamant haben will dann weckst du da schon eine Woche oder so na komm wir ziehen. Ob das wirtschaftlich ist.
Okay ja ja.
Weil wenn du da alleine an Strom für die Mikrowelle anderthalb kW reinhämmern durchgehend das ganze noch kühlen muss von außen weil das Plasma erhitzt halt die ganze Anlage muss die Anlage von außen kühlen.
Haushaltsstrom den muss Eltern entsprechend kostengünstig bereitgestellt bekommen damit das Wort noch wirtschaftlich.
Richtig da sind wir wieder bei Indien oder ähnlichem.
Ja weil aber man die Sonnenenergie ist dieselbe.
Ja ja ja ja aber da ist halt insgesamt dann eher billiger.
Wir sind aber ehrlich gemacht mit dem Prozess noch nicht so ganz fertig weil ich habe dir nur die halbe Wahrheit da dazu gesagt ja weil.
Achso so alleine wird es nicht funktionieren.
Ja doch aber da ich habe den Teil des zum Teil unterschlagen der da auch noch passiert im Plasma.
Und zwar der Diamant der sich also der Kohlenstoff der sich an dem Diamant anlagert der macht das nicht immer als Diamant der macht das manchmal auch als Graphit.
Und dann hast du mit Graphitschicht auf dem Diamant deshalb ist das so.
Dass der atomare Wasserstoff nicht nur die,
Aufgabe hat den zu heizen den Kristall sondern diese atomarer Wasserstoff jetzt auch das graffit immer wieder weg.
Was heißt Winter Graphit wächst auf einem Diamant dann wird das vom vom atomaren Wasserstoff aus dem Platz nach kurze Zeit später auch wieder weggeätzt.
Weil cool weil Grafit eine weniger starke Bindung hat als der Diamant wenn man ganz genau nimmt der Diamant selbst wird auch vom Wasserstoff weggeätzt.
Aber so in der Gesamtwahrscheinlichkeit nicht so viel.
Richtig das ist immer so du du weckst irgendwas damit sie der wecker Ärztin weckst du wieder was damit zu der weggeätzt und so weiter das immer so Nicolas da Tomatensoße 5 Schritte vor 3 zurück.
Uns die wahrscheinlich gerade die Apps Wahrscheinlichkeit für Graffitis um Vielfaches höher als die von Diamant und das heißt am Ende des Prozesses bleibt halt nur Diamant stehen.
Auch wenn zwischenzeitlich einiges an Graphit erzeugt wurde wird es dann auch gleich wieder weg gewaschen.
Richtig genau was am Ende bleibt halt Diamant über.
Muss den ganzen Prozess über mit der Mikrowelle da drauf hauen weil sonst regt sich dann natürlichen duscht.
Davon wird das Plasma aus und du hast keine keine radikale mehr die sich anlagern was kein atomaren Wasserstoff mehr.
Diesen darf nur eine Variante der Niederdruck Synthese das ist die elegante,
aus den Achtzigern aber mal in den Achtzigern das erste Mal war zu Beginn der 80er das erste Mal Diamanten auf diese Art hergestellt dadurch kann man den Prozess relativ sauber halten weil man hat ja im Wesentlichen nur den Diamant.
Die Kammer drum herum und die Mikrowellen und die Ausgangs Gase die man da rein hämmert eine Methode die ein bisschen älter ist.
Wenn man eine Nachfrage nach wie viel von diesem Methan.
Verschwindet das Methan dazu sagen am Ende im Idealfall komplett und wird vollständig in Diamant Schultour gemacht oder muss man ein Vielfaches an Kohlenstoff Vorhaben weil nur ein kleiner Teil letztenendes wirklich auf dem Diamant bleibt.
Letzteres man muss einen großen Teil also im großen Teil also ein großer Teil geht in den Auspuff sozusagen also durch die durch die Pumpe ab mal draußen und nur ein kleiner Teil wird tatsächlich in den Diamant eingebaut.
Dann musst auch permanent neuen zu führen.
Permanent Neumann hatten Gas Strom der dadurch geht,
und der liegt so also kommt auch immer drauf an was man machen möchte aber jetzt bei den Sachen die ich gemacht habe mir kannst jetzt nicht auf Wachstumsrate an sondern auch was anderes so bei einem bei dem Gasgemisch von dem halben Liter also ein halber Standard Liter pro Minute.
Was heißt ein halber Liter bei einem bar der der pro Minute durch geht aber das Ding der Woche läuft geht aber viel durch.
Das Methan ist jetzt durchaus leicht zu generierende Ressource.
Ja das schon aber keine sehr also wie gesagt es ist immer immer die Frage was du erreichen willst mit deinem Prozesse wenn du viel diam.
Rein das ist jetzt.
Genau,
wenn du viel Diamant machen möchtest kannst du einfach mit annehmen billigen Wasserstoff nehmen und durch Hermann was ich gemacht habe oder was man was viele Wissenschaftler auch machen möchten ist sie ja dieses also wir machen dir man ja nicht weil wir Schmucksteine haben wollen,
können wir haben machen Diamant weil das Material halt besonders ist das Material werden ja schon gesagt dass hart also als Herz Domlager für Canon Diamant hat die höchste bekannte Wärmeleitung die in der Natur vorkommt und zwar fünfmal höher ungefähr als Kupfer.
Das Kühlkörper aus Diamant wären sehr geil.
Dollar Steuer.
Ja ja das ist jetzt die Frage wie man synthetisch machen kann.
Das auch relativ meine wenn man nur so ein bisschen super leitende.
Ja so Supraleiter machen das dann auch treuer ne das ist.
Nicht suprava also.
Einfach toll was ich wenn jetzt ein Bauteil etwas an einer Stelle extrem darauf ankommt was ab zu leiten an Hitze dann kann man da vielleicht mal ein bisschen Diamant zum Einsatz bringen brauche nicht so viel dafür dann wäre das topfständer Anwendung.
Genau Diamant als Kühlkörper wäre super man kann Diamant auch gezielt verunreinigen also dotieren das macht man der Halbleiterindustrie auch mit Silizium,
wenn man kann Diamant genauso verunreinigen z.b. mit Bor dann wird er elektrisch leitend und,
man kann da weil Diamant hat so eine hohe Wärmeleitung und soweit hat und auch noch ein paar andere geile Eigenschaften unglaublich viel Strom durch jagen man kann für Hochleistungselektronik Diamant unglaublich interessant.
Aber könnte sich so eine kleine CPU bauen die sozialen richtig hoch getaktet werden.
Ja da kommen wir zum Problem das Diamant also mit der sich die Diamanten und hier auch schon sehr sehr lange beschäftigt man muss ja das ein bisschen aber du weißt ja für für CPUs oder generell für die Juden braucht man PN Übergänge,
oder NPN Transistoren also Dotierung,
einmal mit mit irgendwas was hat als Donator wirken irgendwas was als Akzeptor wird also irgendwo muss dann macht ja so verunreinigen dass du entweder freie Elektronen hast die sich irgendwie bewegen können da drin oder,
Löcher Elektronen Löcher die sich frei bewegen können.
Das eine geht beim Diamant ganz gut und zwar das mit den Löchern und das ist wenn man boar einbringt.
Das kriegt man in großen Mengen Diamant gelöst beim Wachstum und hat auch eine Ionisierungsenergie dass man super das Ding als Stromleiter nehmen kann das die dass die P Dotierung problematisch ist die n-Dotierung.
Diamant halt so rum reinigen dass es elektronenüberschuss hat ist sehr schwer.
Man kann da mal guckt halt im Periodensystem was ist denn rechts vom Kohlenstoff könnte man den reinhämmern damit man mehr Elektronen drin hat und da ist das nächste was da steht ist Stickstoff.
Stickstoffkammer super in Diamant reinhämmern in vielen vielen Diamanten ist auch sehr sehr viel Stickstoff drin.
Weiß Verunreinigung.
Verunreinigung das macht die Diamanten gelb.
Alle Diamanten die aus der pressen kommen aus der hochdruckpressen die sind fast alle knallgelb weil halt viel Stickstoff mit drin ist,
dieser Stickstoff liegt aber energetisch im Bändermodell also von den Energieniveaus so ungünstig,
dass der als Halbleiter also als Donat ja nee warte mal das ist dann also dass der Wandmodell nicht zu gebrauchen ist.
Der also die die Bandlücke zwischen dem Niveau dass der Stickstoff reinbringen und dem Niveau das von Diamant kommt im Bändermodell ist so groß dass das nichts nicht zu gebrauchen ist.
Was heißt man muss andere Sachen nehmen da ist der nächste Kandidatin man nehmen könnte für eine n-Dotierung der Phosphor.
Da wird schon gesundheitlich nicht mehr also bei der Herstellung ist schon doof.
Phosphor ist nicht so geil damit will man nicht unbedingt im Labor arbeiten kann man aber auch machen Phosphor geht kriegt man aber nicht mehr so gut wie ein Diamant rein sehr guter Kandidat noch für eine kleine Bandlücke ist Arsen.
Auch nicht sondern.
Du merkst wird also tatsächlich Bauelemente aus Diamant zu machen also die Juden Leuchtdioden der auch super interessant ist nicht ganz so leicht weil die Änderung tatsächlich ein massives Problem darstellt bei Diamant.
Ich fasse zusammen war eine schöne Idee so Diamanten CPU zu bauen aber steht noch vor zehn herausfordern.
Steht vor technischen Herausforderungen.
Gelöst sind so aber grundsätzlich kann man festhalten Name leitet ein Diamant super und das ist dann sozusagen auch an Ergebnisse der kristallinen Struktur nämlich an.
Ja und zwar ein Fachmann sogar relativ leicht nachvollziehen kann Kohlenstoff an sich steht ja in also hat die Ordnungszahl 6,
also 6 Protonen ist relativ früh im Periodensystem kommt das vor das heißt die Kerne Kunstoff an sich ist sehr leicht merkt man ja auch man Diamant in der Hand hat oder so oder ein Stück Kohle das ist nicht besonders schwer.
Kutsche wann sicher sehr leicht die Bindung zwischen den einzelnen Atomen ist aber sehr stark also sehr hart.
Kann sich das vorstellen also man Tischtennisbälle mit sehr sehr harten Federn aneinander kleben würde.
Wenn ich den ersten antippe dann ist der Impuls des antiken quasi instantan bei dem letzten in der Reihe angekommen.
Also da ist wenig Trägheit und deshalb hat jemand also bei dem man es genauso deshalb hat Diamantene Särge hohe Wärmeleitfähigkeit.
Weil Wärme letztenendes in den Atomen der Bewegung ist und die sich dann halt ganz gut fortsetzen.
Genau.
Diamant Diamant ist für Physiker unglaublich geiles Material weil das ist nicht nur die Wärmeleitung sondern eigentlich fast jede Eigenschaft egal was ist Diamant in der Materialeigenschaft entweder das beste oder unter den Top 10.
Palm also Herze Wärmeleitfähigkeit elektronenbeweglichkeit Löcher Beweglichkeit,
Transparenz Diamant ist unglaublich transparent der verbessert Diamant gerne für Laser Fenster und so benutzt also in,
normales Glas wird ein Fenster haben wir können durch gucken ne aber z.b. Infrarotstrahlung geht ja nicht so gut da durch oder ultraviolette Strahlung auch nicht was man.
Oder Handystrahlung.
Ja oder sowas da ist jemand komplett anders mit Diamant geht fast alles durch also das absorbiert so gut wie nichts.
Das hat mit Diamant mit Diamant Fenstern könnte ich auch mal besser Telefon.
Ja mit Diamant Fenstern mehr empfangen.
Okay was heißt das macht auf einen Teil des disappears aus.
Ja das ist der Grund warum wir als als wissen also warum man sich als Naturwissenschaftler mit diesem Material beschäftigt.
Weiß einfach toll ist und das nicht nur in einer Achse sein ist es einfach in vielerlei Hinsicht immer das Maximum oder zumindest einen Mitglied der Top Ten.
SSS biokompatibel künstliche Gelenke aus Diamant super Kunststoff.
Weil Kohlenstoff ist halt nicht gefährlich und kann dem Körper nichts weil wir bestehen ja selber aus recht viel davon war kein Wasser an.
Genau oder darüber fragst du mich.
Aber es ist ein einiges Wissen kohlenstoffbasierte viel habe ich gelernt.
Was sind denn jetzt meine lange zum bisschen schon an Anwendungen für Diamanten.
So und zwar sowohl was,
wird so gemacht und Delfine so in wissenschaftlicher Hinsicht was man so zu Forschung Benutzern Wo kommen Diamanten heutzutage für diesen Einsatz verlangt lange Zeit war es ja selten dann muss man halt erstmal nichts damit umzugehen dann warst Du toll das,
dass man erstmal nur noch Schmuck draus machen wollte da steckte das ja sozusagen in in in keinerlei Gerät schafft und ich vermute jetzt mal allein durch diese Synthese Möglichkeiten und auch wenn es halt immer noch viel Energie braucht aber,
normal hat sich das halt einfach mal geleistet ist es ja dann auch sehr erstrebenswert überhaupt erstmal so ein Werkstoff herzustellen der bestimmte Dinge vielleicht überhaupt erst ermöglicht,
Basis dieser ganzen Eigenschaften gerade aufgezählt hast Wärmeleitfähigkeit Härte Transparenz et cetera pp wo wo sind Diamanten.
Sind Diamanten ganz viele gerade von den synthetischen Diamanten aus den hochdruckpressen sind in Werkzeugen.
Jetzt nicht das was man sich also das erste woran ich damals gedacht habe hat das Werkzeug braucht man so auf der Drehbank.
Schneidewerkzeug.
Interspar ja zuschneidewerkzeug da kommt es schon vor oder um 13 Uhr.
Überdrehte wären ja auch dicke Drähte werden durch dünne kleine Löcher gezogen sie dünner zu machen und dafür nimmt man auch gerne Diamant was man mit Diamanten über also fast überhaupt nicht bearbeiten kann leider.
Wofür das Loch nimmt man das Diamant weil es so ziemlich ausgefräst werden kann.
Niemand zieht es durch einen also durch einen Diamant Qual also genau ja ja genau.
Durch ein Diamant Loch erstmal dich also aber die Diamant bleibt einfach weiter so fest ist unbeeindruckt von dem Metall.
Genau jetzt genau.
Eisen kann man leider nicht mit Diamant bearbeiten.
Das ist sehr schade also wenn man jetzt eine Drehbank hat und da irgendwie ein Stück Stahl drauf hat wird man das nicht mit einem also nicht mit dem Diamant dauerhaft ordentlich bearbeiten können weil so ein Diamant wird ja heiß,
beim Arbeiten genau wie das Werkstück und Diamant ist sehr gut in also Kohlenstoff ist sehr gut in Eisen löslich.
Was heißt der Diamant löst sich früher oder später nach und nach in deinem Werkstück auf.
Also Bruder so hart ist hat er trotzdem noch atomische Freunde mit denen er sich gerne irgendwie zu irgendwas verbinden möchte zu welchen Molekülen.
Richtig genau und in in Eisen ist Kohlenstoff hat sehr gut lösbar und deshalb kannst du mit mit Diamant Eisen nicht wirklich gut bearbeiten zumindest nicht auf Dauer.
Okay aber das erklärt auch warum die Diamanten überhaupt entstehen weil dann den ganzen Magmar worauf feel so ein kerndl Erde ist ja auch viel heißes Eisen zusammen automatisch viel Kohlenstoff.
Jade die man entsteht aber ja nicht im Kern sondern eher so eine Kruste oben da ist nicht mehr so viel mit Eisenmann.
Also vergiss mitten im Wald.
Ja aber also wie gesagt du eisenbearbeitung mich aber alles andere halt ne alles von von Anubis sonst war okay hallo, wann das nicht aber generell Schneidwerkzeuge schneit und zerspanwerkzeuge wenn es nicht Eisen ist kann man super mit Diamant machen.
Dafür die naheliegendste Bohrköpfe.
Das was das man nicht auf dem Schirm hatte als allererstes das ist auch der Grund warum diamantsynthese in den 50er 60er Jahren so stark halt erforscht wurde und zwar.
Richtig Ölförderung deshalb wenn man sich mal angucken wo die wo die Diamant pressen stehen die so Diamanten machen dann ist es in Russland.
Viele stehen davon in Russland also die Russen sind sehr sehr gut in Diamant also Diamanten machen die Chinesen mittlerweile auch.
In den treffen und die ersten synthetischen Diamanten kam tatsächlich,
nicht aus den USA sondern von einer nicht aus Russland auch nicht aus den USA sondern ich glaube es war die Firma Ada jetzt muss ich einmal ganz gucken wo die Sitze nicht glaubt die sitzen Schweden.
Hammer Schweden.
Ja das klingt nach Skandinavien.
Ja immer da kam auf jeden Fall die ersten also da wurden das erste Mal synthetisch Diamanten in der Presse gemacht.
Allmänna svenska elektriska aktiebolaget.
Ja Mann,
es ist aber also dafür zumindest Internetquellen guck dass das die erste dokumentierte Hochdruck Synthese dieser Firma General Electric führte auch viel gemacht und auch kurz danach glaube ich hier die erste Synthese gewesen wär aber genau da ist aller erster wo irgendwie tatsächlich mal Diamante kritisiert hat,
ist nicht ganz so einfach zu sagen weil dass das sieht man auf mein Paypal zum Fünfziger nur von General Electric so oder so noch in die Finger bekommt das ein fetter Stempel top secret drauf.
Weil Kalter Krieg wichtige also wirklich wichtiges Wissen für halt wie du schon sagtest Öl also überkopf RZB.
Wurde später weniger,
wie gesagt mittlerweile könnte Chinesen auch ganz gut mit den mit den Diamanten auch die Niederdruck Synthese kriegen mittlerweile viele viele viele Länder hin das kam so in den Achtzigern wie gesagt auf mit den mit den,
Mikrowellen reag,
porn die hat jemand gemacht haben es gibt noch einfache Reaktoren die gab es ein bisschen früher das sogenannte hot filament Verfahren da ist der Aufbau ungefähr so Komplexmittel Glühbirne,
ist nämlich im Wesentlichen der Glühbirne du hast wieder deine Vakuumkammer da liegt der Diamant drin.
Unsere du hast oben wieder die Gase die hat Strom aber anstatt einer Mikrowelle da rein zu rein zu hämmern hast du ein Glühdraht der da oben drüber gespannt ist.
Und da kommt die Energie halt aus diesem trat der dann halt die.
Glühdraht der der der der imitiert doch dann bestimmt viele Stoffe und dann verunreinigt.
Richtig genau und deshalb kriegst du damit keine richtig sauber also dann kriegt auch saure diamantener mit hin aber mit einer Mikrowelle Christo deutlich bessere.
Unser ich rede ganze zum sauberen Diamanten sauber ist für Schmucksteine Formigal weil das was du Anwendung synthetischen weißen Diamant machst ist der für Physiker immer noch dreckig.
Das immer noch immernoch direkt drin.
Aber optisch ist da nichts.
Optisch ist der nächste can aber von Physik costume dreckig.
Was für uns unglaublich interessant ist also was ein Punkt ist Warum Diamant für uns Unglaublichen xantis sind bestimmte Arten von Fehlstellen dadrin bestimmte Gitter defekt aber da drauf gehe ich gleich ein wenn wir zu den anwenden also wir waren ja gerade bei den Anwendungen,
und das ist eine der Anwendungen diese diese Fehlstellen haben mich,
coole Eigenschaften die bilden quantenmechanische Systeme die bei Raumtemperatur stabil sind das heißt.
Damit du gleich ein bisschen eventuell noch ein bisschen was zu erzählen aber Diamant findet Anwendung in Form von.
Jakubitz Imgrund Lukas cubots in Diamant implementieren.
Also die Basis für Quad.
Die Basis für,
fun Computer genau und nach dem ähnlichen Prinzip also wenn du das also was ähnlichen Art funktioniert ist Diamant als Sensor zu benutzen kann es mit dieser bestimmten Art von Fehlstelle didun Diamant gezielt erzeugt kannst du extrem empfindlich Magnetfelder messen.
2 nanotesla Bereich und das ist sehr interessant für ihr habt für die Struktur von Molekülen um sich die Struktur von verschiedenen Molekülen anzugucken.
Also kurz also ganz kurz gesagt man kann wenn man sehr sauberen Diamant macht kann man da mit Sensoren bauen sehr empfindliche Sensoren.
Und haben.
Man kann man Nähte schon die Struktur eines Moleküls ertasten.
Im Grunde könnte man damit anfangen sowas wie ein MRT für Moleküle damit zu bauen sind die Größenordnung Tomographie für Moleküle.
Also Magnetresonanztomographie diese dicken Maschinen wo man irgendwie Tunis vorher seine ganzen Haus Schlüssel abgeben sollte sonst gibt's großes Hallo.
Das ist natürlich dass du da da sind wir noch weit in der Zukunft zu Richtung und so aber du kannst damit die Magnetfelder von ja tatsächlich von von einzelnen Verbindungen messen.
Ablama noch ein bisschen so in der Gegend war dass ich meine so von den Bock Köpfen zu Molekülmasse und da ist ja schon mal weiter.
Eisensprung.
Bei dem Backofen wie muss man sich denn das vorstellen sind die ominöse so besonders dünnen Diamant Schicht bedampft damit dann das dahinter nicht kaputt geht oder baut man da so richtige Diamant Schnitzereien die ordentlich einen weg haben.
Da brauchst du dicke Diamant Klötze rein und zwar die aus dem Treffen wir auf dem Treffen rausfallen die ordentlich was wegschaffen weil Diamant Schichten irgendwo drauf machen ist nicht so einfach,
du kannst so so diamantähnliche Schichten machen das nennt sich diamond-like Karben,
das ist eine Mischung aus SP3 und SP2 Hybridisierung also eine Mischung aus es ist nicht Graphit es ist nicht Diamant es ist noch ein Gemisch dazwischen.
Das ist auch nicht kristallin sondern das ist amorph.
Also als als Beschichtung von so Armbändern Armbanduhren und so.
Genau das ist so schwarz deshalb bei Diamond black für das für das iPhone hatte ich auch erst gedacht so haben die DLC da drauf gemacht aber haben sie nicht.
Bei der Uhr haben sie es gemacht ja.
Macht und hält es.
Also ich habe das hier auf diesem Armband und du siehst immer noch aus wie.
ADAC ist auch sehr hart ist in der Industrie auch schon lange Standard dass man sowas halt groß aufbringt auf halt auf Sachen die hier als Verschleißschutz Schicht,
Barbie arbeit Isenburg Köpfen und so da machst du tatsächlich eher so dicke Klunker also dicke Klunker ist jetzt auch übertrieben sind Zentimeter Kubikzentimeter davon mehrere die fest verankert und das und dann halt die Spitzen.
Sie müssen groß genug sein damit wir eins haben aber trotzdem anderen mechanischen halt irgendwo haben wir müssen irgendwie auch ordentlich gedreht und bewegt werden.
Weil bei dieser Beschichtung wenn du jetzt Diamant auf dem fremd sitzt also Fett auf nicht Diamant aufbringen möchtest dann bist du ein breite Hydro Epitaxie,
habe ich vorhin erwähnt habe dann möchtest du ja im Grunde Diamant auf einem fremd Kristall wachsen.
Das war lange lange Zeit zum bisschen der Heilige Gral der diamantsynthese weil also das was wir haben willst sind Einkristalle.
Also du möchtest nicht wie bei wie bei deinem Schlüssel irgendwie tausende kleine Kristalle haben die in verschiedene Richtungen orientiert sind,
sondern du willst einen einzigen Kristall haben weil dieser eine einzige Kristall der hat dann die Eigenschaften die Diamant hat die hohe Wärmeleitfähigkeit,
die Härte und das ganze andere Zeugs drumherum das hat der polykristallines Diamanten nicht unbedingt.
Da geht die Wärmeleitung z.b. schon ganz in den Keller weil die.
Den Übergängen der sozial nicht mehr so gut.
Aber von Übergängen nicht mehr so gut funktioniert und auch alle anderen auf die Schallgeschwindigkeit ist da drin viel geringer und so alles ist nicht so dolle du willst Einkristalle haben.
Aber wenn man jetzt so zeigen die Möglichkeit hätte auf einem anderen billiger einfacher herzustellen in kristall einfach so eine Diamant Kristall Schicht aufzutragen die damit aber mehr oder weniger fest verbunden ist dann könnte man sowas machen wie Küchenmesser.
Ja mann oh mann mann kann man kann auch noch viel mehr machen das Problem ist in mich oder eine Frage ist ja wenn wenn man Diamant seit den Achtzigern wachsen kann ne warum haben wir noch nicht so Diamantpulver,
warum haben wir noch keine großen Baum habe ich nicht im Keller großen Diamant zu Hause,
der Grund ist dass wir diese Einkristalle bisher oder lange lange Zeit nur um taktisch wachsen konnten das heißt auf Diamant wieder.
Zeit wenn du einen großen Diamant wachsen willst brauchst du einen noch größeren Diamant als Substrat.
Also als als Ausgangsstoff weil du ja immer nur maximal auf dem drauf wachsen kannst und dann runterschneiden.
Der größte Diamant in so haben können das ist halt holen Juwelen bei der Queen anklopfen und ich glaube die ist nicht so begeistert wenn du sagst du willst den scheiden in Scheiben schneiden weil du so rate braun.
Ja genau.
Funktioniert er nicht so gut deshalb war lange lange Zeit oder ist es immer noch so der Heilige Gral die heteroepitaxie von Einkristallen also fremd Kristall.
Sei es jetzt ein Silizium Einkristall die komme ja sehr sauber machen weil wir es ja seitdem seit wann machen wir Halbleiter der 50er.
Wasserzulauf Anschluss genauso 60er 70er ging so richtig los.
Eine auf auf jeden Fall Elite Missian Material dass wir als Menschheit sehr sehr rein und sehr groß produzieren können,
und genau sowas will man für Diamanten eigentlich auch haben weil wenn man das Material nutzen möchte,
uns um möglichst große Diamanten smarna zu welcher Größe muss man irgendwie nach Möglichkeit die hetro Epitaxie in den Griff kriegen das ist leider nicht ganz so einfach weil du musst einen Kristall haben der der Diamantstruktur sehr sehr ähnlich ist.
Und auf dem der Diamant dann auch als Einkristall weiter wächst.
Da gabs ein Forscher der hat das lange Zeit auf Iridium gemacht also der hat Iridium,
dünne Iridium Schichten aufgedampft,
die hat als ein Kristall gewachsen sind wieder auf andere Substraten und versucht dadrauf Diamant zu wachsen da gab es auch auch während des Wachsens Spannungen und Versetzungen und hat trotzdem irgendwo es plötzlich noch Korngrenze gewachsen und du hast kein Eingriff Teil mehr sondern.
Anderes,
so Forscher ist sei der Herr Schreck also Professor Schreck der hat es ich glaube das ist nicht das ist jetzt von 2016 tatsächlich nach ich glaube der Vorstand im Thema seit 25 Jahren und zwar nur daran,
halt diese in ein Kratzer auf dem Fremdwort zu.
Max und er hat sich vor über 20 Jahren schon quasi war er der Meinung das muss wenn dann mit Iridium gehen als als Schicht.
Aber Englisch.
Ja doch schon er hat recht behalten ausging.
Aber nicht einfach mit Iridium nur sondern wenn man sich mal die Publikationen anguckt wieder aufgemacht hat da kam erstens noch ein Prozess mit dazu,
bin noch mit entwickelt hat der das,
den Übergang zu der Diamant Schicht halt verbessert hat und das System dass er benutzt mittlerweile besteht nicht nur aus Iridium sondern so ein ganzes Schichtsystem dass der ersten Mal wächst und da drauf dann am Ende Diamant.
Hydrium stabilisiert mit Zinkoxid dadrauf Iridium dadrauf weiß ich nicht was also lange lange geforscht viele Doktoranden haben da in der Richtung was gemacht.
Aber der Airtrack constat 60 2016 war es wie gesagt paper veröffentlichen.
Von einem Hydro epitaktisch gewachsenen Einkristall.
Bin auf einem Bild auch in der Hand hat der sieht noch nicht besonders hübsch aus also ist am Rand noch Kaffeemenge bei und so aber es ist ein Einkristall und der ist ungefähr so Bierdeckel groß.
Der hat eine Grundfläche von dem Bierdeckel.
Das ist so der fetteste synthetisch hergestellte Kristall Diamant.
Genau ist es vor allem ein Einkristall.
Also ein Kristall Diamant genommen.
Genau und auf diese Minecraft Teil der ist irgendwie dessen paar Millimeter dick auf dem kann man jetzt einfach also einfach einfach sein ist auch nicht ganz einfach mal gucken wie es weitergeht aber auf diesem Kristall könnte man homo epitaktisch weiterwachsen.
Das kann man schon länger das hat man schon da fährt man im Griff sage ich mal das können mehrere.
Was heißt dieser auf diese Art und Weise große hergestellte Kristall könnte quasi so als Bootstrap Plattform für größere.
Genau ja genau also.
Ausweise wenn man erstmal so in Scheibchen schneiden kann man so sagen aus jedem Scheibchen theoretisch dann.
Amazon richtig inkubations Zentrum für kleine Diamanten oder große Diamanten.
Kleines Gutachter der Schalter bei diese Technik immer noch weiter zu entwickeln und halt wirklich der hat eine Firma jetzt auch gegründet der verkauft Diamant Wafer also Diamant ein Kristall in Wafer Größe.
Wenn du da drauf hier zuwächst also Diamanten dann also ich glaube wir leben das noch und ich warte eigentlich darauf dass du der.
Von also das quasi die Kronjuwelen der Queen also die größten Diamanten der Welt die wir aktuell haben von synthetischen Diamanten übertroffen wird.
Dass wir als Menschheit in der Lage sind Diamanten zu machen die größer sind als die die in der Natur vorkommen.
Wie groß werden die Kronjuwelen.
Currysauce Baseball wie sich der.
Queen oder was ist nicht sowas also gibt's den großen Stern von Afrika 530 Karat der zweitgrößte geschliffene Diamant der Welt.
Ich habe tatsächlich von diesem großen Diamanten noch nicht viel bzw ich glaube noch gar keinen gesehen.
Ich wollte mir immer mal in Dresden den den Grünen Dresdner angucken das halt ein grüner Diamant.
Und ein sehr bekannter und sehr große die Geschichte also.
Pass mal auf hier kurz der Cullinan das war ein.
3106 Karat damit dreimal größer als der nächste Südafrika gefunden 1905.
Ja
Wurde in 105 Steine aufgespalten die neun größten sind Teil der britischen Kronjuwelen.
Genau das ist.
Wow der will doch geguckt haben den gefunden.
Ja das und er wird nichts davon gehabt haben.
Denn das was ist denn 3ch bestimmt 3106 Karat ist wie viel ist denn das.
Karat 1 Karat sind 0,2 g.
Also durch 5 und dann hat man das in Gramm.
Ja aber wie gesagt noch miteinander das ist halt so sehr sehr leicht das Ding ist schon groß gewesen sehr.
Zucker also man das meint das wäre sozusagen das Ziel also weil das ist ja zurzeit der Größe der gefunden wurde also.
Ja dass das also dass du dass das wäre so das wäre soll das hin das wäre sonst Heinz dann ne also da hast du da hast du nicht viele von aber du kannst halt hier so ne größter Diamant der Welt den habe ich gemacht oder der der wurde gemacht.
Normaler nicht viel von.
Ich habe sie schon so hast du davon aber eigentlich willst du Wafer machen du willst Wafer bauen um Diamant halt um halt Diamant Elektronik mal an den Start zu bringen.
Um Diamant halt als Material zu verwenden dass du viel viel mehr von als das als Schmuckstein zu verwenden.
Verkleidet man das ist jetzt Schmuck sein muss habe ich ja nicht gesagt so aber vielleicht hat mir auch eine Anwendung für einen großen Diamanten.
Ja ja.
Meine wenn man immer ordentlich schleifte.
Ja aber da sind da sind die anderen das sind die anderen Varianten also diese cubitt Ecke oder so doch deutlich interessanter.
Was er die die Anwendung ist wenn man so ein großen Einkauf Berlin Diamant hat sind optische Anwendungen das zu Hochleistungslaser oder so.
Dass du den dafür nutzt weil dadurch dass Diamant hochgradig transparent ist kannst du da halt Fenster ausbauen für Laser du kannst da.
Laserleistung durch Pumpen bis zum Gehtnichtmehr und dadrin will halt im Grunde nichts absorbiert oder nichts geht an Verlustleistung also David die Verlustleistung ist falsch Wort also es gibt kein Verlust an diesem Fenster.
Im Wesentlichen durch das Fenster auch nicht heiß wird.
Bye bye richtig Hochleistungslaser und so hat er immer das Problem dass die optican die Du dafür brauchst halt,
Teil der Leistung absorbieren heiß werden gekühlt werden müssen oder das Licht nicht so brechen wie du es brauchst und das hast du beim Diamanten echt der Diamant ist halt sein eigener Kühlkörper.
Und ist eh hochgradig transparentes heißt das Licht GTI durch und wird nicht also wird nicht absorbiert.
Dass mir vielleicht ein bisschen großen Diamanten zum Warp-Antrieb bauen oder wieso.
Ja ich glaube nicht.
Nein wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ist schon gut aber ich meine auch solche wissenschaftlichen Meilensteine wollen ja erstmal genommen werden und das hat die anwendung ganz andere sind ist klar.
Als als ich mit meiner Diplomarbeit damals angefangen habe es jetzt auch schon bisschen her,
hätte ich nie gedacht dass ich mein PayPal also da wird sie auch schon dass der Schreck das macht da hatte ich auch schon wieder zum Jahr netto von mir meinte auch so ja das Wasser erschreckter geschafft hatte letzten weiß nicht was zu der Zeit waren 18 19 Jahren ist schon echt erstaunlich aber ich glaube,
vielmehr also mit dem mit dem Iridium da ist man irgendwie so langsam durch ne ich hätte nie gedacht dass ich mein PayPal sehe wo der wirklich so ein Bierdeckel großen Wafer in der Hand hat.
Hattest schon SPECT für also ich find's super.
Haben jetzt die die die die die Gegenwart Anwendung jetzt schon ausreichend beschrieben was wir hatten jetzt an die Bohrköpfe das so rein mechanisch dann,
hast du gesagt okay für Laser ist und Diamant auch super einfach so als Austritt Schutz Optik.
Sensoren.
Jonas angedeutet.
Also wir sind Magneten so ein aber auch noch andere Sensoren z.b. am LHC die beam loss Sensoren also wenn der wenn der wenn der Strahl halt aus dem aus der.
Www nennt man das bei dem Beschleunigern also wenn er nicht da bleibt wo er soll sondern halt leicht aus der aus der Krümmung rausgeht muss man das irgendwie detektieren und das macht man auch mit Diamant Sensoren.
Weil Diamant halt die die Strahlung halt ab kann der wenn du dann Sensor aus Silizium oder Rainbows der irgend so ein bisschen von dem Strahl der gerade auf Lichtgeschwindigkeit beschleunigt wurde abbekommt er ist halt durch der Zweck der.
Wetter Beckum Diamant hält das halt aus und es wird kann man mit Diamant Hallsensoren bauen die halte diese diesen Byblos,
halt halten also sobald man ihn wie sieht der der streiten ganz klein bisschen raus dann detektieren dass diese Byblos,
Monitore sozusagen und Köln hat die Magnetfelder entsprechend anpassen da falls der Streit wieder auf auf der Bahn gehalten wird.
Aber die Dinger also in der Forschung benutzt man Diamant auch als Sensor tatsächlich versuchen energetische strahlen.
Paulinghof noch Mann Mensch kann man aus Diamant bauen.
Das sind so Mensch das sind.
So so kleine winzig kleine Zahnräder sososo Mischung aus aus mechanischen und elektrischen Bauteilen also so Mikrosysteme.
Barbie.
Sonano Mechanik oder was.
Ja sind Nano System Micro ich weiß nicht wofür ich muss mal kurz gucken für die Abkürzung MEMS steht man sagt das immer so häufig ohne.
Mems microelectromechanical systems mems.
Micro.
Mechanical systems microelectromechanical systems.
Das weiß ich nicht dass du das einfach niemanden bloßen Auge nicht mehr sieht das sind so kleinste Strukturen wo Sachen irgendwie schwingen oder auch als Temperatursensoren benutzt werden und ähnliches.
Also im Prinzip auch wieder so die Sensorik.
Im Wesentlichen auch wieder so die die Sensorik.
Jetzt haben wir ja den Diamant so als solchen haben wir ja.
Jetzt schon ausführlich beschrieben wie verhält sich denn so der Diamant zu all den anderen,
Edelstein di manzo Kenzo,
na da gibt's ja dann noch die Smaragde und die Rubine und es läuft ja irgendwie ein gewisser Hinsicht auch auf der ähnliche Strukturen aus oder nicht sind das ganz andere Dinge oder haben die sehr viel gemeinsam.
Im Grunde haben wir relativ viel gemeinsam also so andere andere Schmucksteine wie Rubine und so weiter das sind ja,
Öffne Männer auch Kristalle also auch im im physikalischen sind Kristalle die bestehen halt nur aus anderen Sachen also Rubin ist im Wesentlichen Aluminiumoxid also Rubin besteht aus Aluminium und Sauerstoff.
Also atomar und Diamant halt nur aus Kohlenstoff und halt immer andere Bildungsstrukturen wie das ganze gebundene wir hatten ja.
Tim Rubin ist kein Kohlenstoff.
Im Rubin ist kein Kunststoff aus Alu Messe besteht aus Aluminium und Sauerstoff und genauso ist das bei Smaragd ich weiß garnicht woraus Smaragd besteht.
Smaragd diese diese ganzen ganzen Kristalle bestehen immer aus.
Ja du diese Edelsteine besteht immer aus irgendwie zwei drei Elementen also zwei drei atomaren Elementen die einer bestimmten Gitterstruktur zusammengesetzt sind es Markt s2b Aluminium Beryllium Silizium und Sauerstoff.
Aber dann in sich auch eine kristalline Struktur aufbauen aber unter Beteiligung mehrerer verschiedener Elemente.
Richtig.
Weil nur dadurch kann dann wiederum diese Struktur hergestellt werden also das was sie was was das Einzelelement an sich gar nicht kennt also irgend eine kristalline Struktur.
Jedoch tut es auch das einzelne Element kennt auch eine kristalline Struktur,
genau beispielsweise beim beim Rubin haben wir ja wie gesagt Aluminiumoxid Aluminium selbst kann auch ein Kristall bilden vivance nur nicht also im allgemeinen Sprachgebrauch gezeigt also sag dann halt nicht Kristall,
Kanada ist halt ein Block Aluminium.
Dieser Blog Aluminium den sieht man das nicht an bei dem normalen Block den du kaufst jetzt nicht so sein aber du kannst mal Spinner Physik bin jetzt dass ich hätte gerne einen Einkristall,
Aluminium Dachbahn kaufen weil du den führenden extrement brauchst oder so dann hast du noch klein Block Aluminium der Kost ungefähr 100 mal soviel wie ich wie ein anderer Block Aluminium aber du weißt dass es ein Einkristall aber ansehen tust du dem das so nicht mit bloßem Auge.
Nein ich kann nicht anders daherkommt.
Die genaue sieht genauso aus aber wenn du ihn die unter Mikroskop also angeschliffen uns anguckt siehst du dass er keine Körner hat der ist halt ein Einkristall.
Knopf und Rubin.
Z.b. Rubin ist auch ein Kristall im allgemeinen Sprachgebrauch hat eine kristalline Struktur besteht aber aus mehr als einem Element.
Diese beiden Elemente Aluminium und.
Sauerstoff sind aber auch wieder in so einer kristallinen Struktur angeordnet und dabei haben wir immer.
Diese verschiedenen diese verschiedenen Gitterstrukturen die von erwähnt habe da kommen noch ein paar zu aber im Wesentlichen hat man immer dieses und jetzt bei kubischen Strukturen Bleibt hat man dieses.
Einfach kubische kubisch raumzentriert kubisch flächenzentriert wenn man weiß nicht was du mal am Atomium.
Brüssel ich gesagt nicht.
Ich auch noch nicht ich will aber unbedingt mal hin weil das Atomium,
ist der name smissen irreführend das ist kein Atom sondern das ist eine Basis Zelle eines Kristallgitters,
was ist diese kubisch raumzentriert kubisch raumzentrierte Geschichte wenn du dir mal was ich durfte dann wenn du ein Browser offen hast,
geh mal ein Bild davon angucken im Atomium das ist ein Würfelwurf jeder Ecke eine Kugel sitzt und im mit in der Mitte des Würfels einer Kugel.
Und das ist die Einheitszelle von Eisen von einer Bestrahlung von einem Zustand von Eisen kubisch raumzentriertes Gitter.
Wenn man davon unendlich viele Amanda packt hat man eine symmetrische Struktur in alle Raumrichtungen,
wie wird unendlich fortsetzt und genauso was hast du bei Kristallen halt immer du hast bei Kristallen immer eine Struktur die sich Simmeth also die sich periodischen alle Richtung fortsetzen diese Struktur muss nicht unbedingt immer aus einzelnen Atomen,
stehen die auf diesen Ecken des Gitters sitzen sondern wo jetzt im emerten also im Atomium eine Kugel auf der Ecke sitzt muss nicht ein Eisenatom sitzen sondern da können auch,
Eisen Aluminium in irgendwas also nur eine Kombination aus mehreren sitzen und die dann halt.
Aber mit dieser Struktur unendlich fortgesetzt in alle Richtung.
Und die Entstehungsbedingungen für diese kristalline Strukturen sind aber auch nicht die gleichen jetzt wie bei dem Diamanten weil.
Für diesen für jedes diesen für jedes Element wenn man Eiskristalle hat und für jede elementare Verbindungen oder so wie z.b. Rubin oder ähnliches halt eigen also immer immer immer anders.
Entsteht ganz woanders brauch.
Unter anderen Bedingungen und so weiter.
Oder Hitze oder so sein was auch immer ist gerade brauch.
Also Druck und Hitze spielen immer immer,
also sind immer Parameter die wichtig sind wenn man immer dieses Phasendiagramm hat aber das reicht meist nicht aufkommen häufig noch andere Sachen hinzu aber es ist für jedes Element für jede Verbindung anders.
Unser eben Grunde ist Diamant demnach eigentlich gar nichts Besonderes es ist nur eine kristalline Form von Kohlenstoff.
Nur halt eine die durch die bindungsstruktur sehr viele physikalischen Profanter Eigenschaften hat die relativ selten in der Natur vorkommt und die die deshalb irgendwie so wertvoll macht.
Gibt es überhaupt noch irgendein anderes Element was so eine ähnliche kristalline formen herstellt die auch noch besonders ist.
Es gibt sogar es gibt sogar Elemente oder elementverbindung die genau die gleiche Struktur wie wie Diamant haben.
Nur halt mit anderen Atomen also anderen Automaten und deshalb nun die Bindungen nicht so hart oder nicht so gleich oder suchst du mir z.b. also dann.
Wer hat das noch gar nicht gemacht aber wir können mal kurz uns die Struktur also die die Bindung Struktur von Diamant angucken die islamisch.
Auch eine dieser komischen Strukturen und zwar die flächenzentrierte das ist der Würfel der auf jeder Flächen Mitte noch mal Atom sitzen hat.
So leicht noch leicht vorzustellen das ist eine sogenannte FCC Struktur face centered cubic.
Das aber nicht alles sondern du hast zwei dieser Gitter und die sind um ein Viertel in der Raumdiagonalen verschoben und dann bekommst du Diamant.
Und welche anderen Elemente findet man auch noch in dieser Struktur.
Elemente jetzt nicht so sehr sondern er also auch elementa mir fällt gerade spontan ehrlich gesagt keine nein mann nennt das Ding nicht nur Diamantstruktur noch Zinkblende Struktur sowas wie Zinksulfid,
hat die gleiche Struktur hat auch so eine 2 und Mainviertel ineinander verschoben kubisch flächenzentrierte Gitter.
Okay aber Zinksulfid ist jetzt nicht als bester Freund des Mädchens bekannt ne.
Aber da da liegt das da liegt das ja auch daran dass es nicht nicht RHEINZINK oder ähnliches ist sondern es ist halt.
Zink und Schwefel und es bildet zwar die gleiche Struktur aber das sind halt andere Atome die miteinander binden und deshalb hat halt auch also er hat halt auch andere Eigenschaften als Diamant.
Also Diamant ist schon like no other.
Diamant is like no other,
und Diamant ist halt sowohl für Physiker als auch irgendwie so weil es hübsch aussieht weil es halt ne besondere Dispersion hat also eine besondere Art der Lichtbrechung deshalb funkelten Diamant so toll halt auch als Schmuckstein irgendwann interessant geworden.
Brennt das eigentlich.
Ja tut es Diamant kann man verbrennen ich weiß nicht mehr wo ich glaube so bei Krupp 400° in einer reinen Sauerstoff Atmosphäre.
Und nur dann.
Ja
so Anrainer also so an Luft da ist so da musst du schon deutlich deutlich heißer werden damit du das Zeug gegen verbrannt bekommen aber es reagiert mit Sauerstoff also verbrennen ist ja im Wesentlichen oxidieren,
also eine Reaktion mit Sauerstoff und Innereien Sauerstoff Atmosphäre also wenn irgend so ein so ein Behälter nimmst du lässt die ganze Zeit Sauerstoff rein babbeln nein an den Diamant sind auch da rein und mach die Flamme von der Seite dann.
Dann fängt er an zu gucken aber wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwie in den Tower of London rein marschieren mir Reisetagebuch Stück davon funny dick.
Ideen ins Feuer wirft dem passiert nichts nein.
Aber warum nicht.
Weil die Kunstoff Atome so fest aneinander gebunden sind doch die gar kein Interesse daran haben andere Bindungen einzugehen.
Wann bist du denn wirklich dann wieder Phasendiagramm soviel Temperatur da auch erzeugen bis sich der Grundeinstellung ändern.
Nee dann dann würdest du den da das komme gleich mal durchsprechen was da passiert du musst genug du musst genug Energie im Grunde aufwenden,
Um und es attraktiv zu machen für die äußersten Kohlenstoffatome dass die halt keinen Bock mehr auf den Kristall haben sondern mit dem Sauerstoff abhauen.
Aber Kristall finde einfach so geil.
Penny supergeil.
Genau also für mich also da ist ja auch immer ich meine jedes dieser einzelne Kohlenstoffatome ist mit vier anderen Atomen mit so einer kovalenten Bindung vor verbunden und die ist halt sehr sehr stark.
Und da muss schon da muss schon erstens eine Menge Sauerstoff in der Nähe sein der halt attraktiv ist und das ganze muss eine gewisse Temperatur haben,
also der hat der Kristall Temperatur hast du davon schon richtig gesagt sind Schwingungen im Kristallgitter nee muss halt so stark schwingen dass das äußerst Datum ganz am Rand schon Bock hat abzuhauen und wenn dann noch der der Sauerstoff vorbeikommt der Hals als Reaktionspartner sehr attraktiv ist,
dann verschwindet halt mal Kohlenstoffatom und haut ab und verbrennt im Grunde.
Was du gerade gesagt hast wenn man Diamant so heiß macht das irgendwie was anderes attraktiver wird das geht auch und zwar ist Diamant.
Bei unserem raumdruck also bei bei unserem bei einem bar,
und bis zu einer gewissen hohen Temperatur eigentlich die stabile Form also das da sagt er ja Kohlenstoff ja ich will Diamant bleiben ich bin Diamant wenn man auf eine bestimmte Temperatur hinausgeht.
Anstieg an einer Stelle.
Dann rutscht man über Song energetisch über Sonnenschein Huckel drüber das ist plötzlich dann ganz vielen also viel viel interessanter für den Diamant sich in graphit umzuwandeln man kann sich das so vorstellen dass mir coole.
Die die Energie darstellt ganz unten in der cool ist wenig Energie ganz oben viel Energie.
Und wenn du das graffit in Diamant umwandeln möchtest dann musst du eine Kugel aus der coole hochrollen solange bist du oben so eine kleine Einbuchtung irgendwo findet auf dem Weg nach oben und diese kleine Einbuchtung der Vorsprung dass es Diamant.
Und da bleibt die Kugel dann liegen,
auch wenn du mit der Temperatur wieder runter gehst bleibt die Kugel trotzdem da oben liegen und bleibt Diamant wenn du jetzt aber die Temperatur wieder hoch machst so dass die dass du diese Kugel wieder ein Stück anhebt oben von dem Plateau wo es gerade liegt drunter,
dann fällt die Kugel wieder ganz runter und wird Graphit.
Temperatur ist das.
Das kommt auf den Druck an bei dem du dich befindest.
Okay also ich denke mir jetzt immer so man hat jetzt so seine Diamanten zu Hause liegen und das Haus brennt ab und aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Da musst du da musst du hören.
Brennt irgendwas extrem heiß weil ich da jetzt noch irgendwelche Stoffe gelagert.
Dudu Lager zu Lager Scotsman Magnesium.
Ja z.b. ja ja.
Ja ja wer kennt das nicht ne,
ich mein du du bist ja häufig beim Fußball und hast ja diese Fackeln bestimmt auch.
Nee aber würde das dann vielleicht und also kann man sich in Szenario vorstellen.
Sehr sehr unwahrscheinlich das muss echt schon richtig heiß brennen also wir haben es mal bei uns eine Anlage mit einem mit dem Diamant geschafft,
den lass mal zu heizen ordentlich da so auf 1500-1600 Grad oder sogar noch drüber.
Und wenn du da nicht aufpasst dann leuchtet der Hals der leuchtet richtig weiß also sehr sehr hell,
bin an der Stelle nicht aufpasst bei dem niedrigen Druck in der Anlage siehst Danninger Stelle so einen zum kleinen schwarzen Punkt und plötzlich macht,
und der komplette Stein ist Graphit.
Aber dann auch instantan.
Dann fast instantan ja.
Weiß ich das dann so sagen durch diese ganze kristalline Struktur auch sofort durch.
Also du kannst mir dabei zugucken wie also wirklich so fast von einer Sekunde auf die andere aus einem Diamant Substrat auf zu teuer eingekauft hast ein Stück Graffiti.
Bewusst wird.
Das Problem wenn man wenn man seine Doktorarbeit in dem Bereich macht wenn man dann zum Professor geht und sagt so schön guten Tag ich müsste da mal ich hätte eine Idee ich hätte eine Proben Reise mit 20 Proben.
Ich brauche mal Substrate dann gehst du hin und sagst du im Grunde dein Professor du musst mal 20 Diamanten einkaufen.
Weil du ja für jede Proben Diamanten brauchst.
Da findet man auch synthetischen Diamanten halt damit mal was definiert das hat die werden im Wesentlichen weltweit von 1 bis 2 Firmen verkaufen sie größte bei der auch eigentlich alle einkaufen wenn du in paper zu Diamant siehst ist es,
immer Element six und Element six ist die Tochter für synthetische Diamanten von die Berge wieder bei Monopol sind.
Mittlerweile gibt es ein paar Japaner und Chinesen die auch nennenswert Diamant Substrate anbieten unter anderem habe ich mal aus Spaß,
von dem ja oder so bei Aliexpress Mahal heute angeschrieben und was sie einem anbieten kann ist echt krass also Einkristalle synthetische kriegt man von den für einen Bruchteil des Preises mittlerweile was Element six von einem verlangt.
Was sind denn so die Preise die man da so aufrufen muss was ist denn Diamant heute so wert.
Die Preise die man so aufrufen muss hängen sehr stark davon ab wie groß der Diamant ist den du haben willst also so die Standard Proben die ich benutzt habe waren so 3 x 3 Millimeter und 3 mm dick sehe aus wie ein Stück im Glas.
Was ist ein Karat auf wenn mir das jetzt auch nicht viel sagt.
Boah was ist das denn.
Also ich meine was ist denn so die Einheit bei meinem ist doch das alles in Karat oder nicht.
Edelsteine ja so Diamant also sowieso drahtindustrie nein.
Spricht man von Gramm oder Größen.
Gramm Gramm oder Gramm oder Größen je nachdem also wenn du wenn du synthetische Diamanten so Einkaufs sprichst du nur von Größe also von soundsoviel cm mal so und so viel Zentimeter oder Millimeter Gewicht ist vollkommen egal.
Und was kann ich jetzt kriegen so in Zentimeter mal Zentimeter ist ja schon ziemlich fett.
Zentimeter mal Zentimeter schon sehr fett das wird die kaum einer verkaufen.
Was was was könnte ich bekommen was es so gängig was ist so der Golf der.
Die die die die Standard Diamant Substrate für Forschung wenn man die so benutzt im Labor sind 3 x 3 mm.
3 x 3 mm Diamant kommt dann aber nicht quadratisch sondern.
Bekommt quadratisch das quadratisch fertig geschnitten das kommt so als kleines Plättchen an.
Das kommt drauf an wie sauber ist wenn er aus einer Presse kommt das dann so ein gelbes und gelbliches Substrat sind aus dem gelbe Stück Glas Kosova wegen Stickstoffs cost zu 80 € dafür zu an.
Wird aber wenn es größer wird zur Wende Zentimeter mal Zentimeter haben Wildverbiss dann schon so bei 2000 € weil du da drauf hier potenziell wachsen kannst also.
Der Preis ist nicht proportional zum Material so zu Materialmenge bei der Größe.
Okay aber so 2000 € führen Zentimeter mal Zentimeter und deshalb so auch so ein perfekter Würfel.
Wahrscheinlich musst du sogar wahrscheinlich muss ein bisschen mehr sogar hin hinblättern im Moment das ist eine dünne Scheibe also die Fläche ist 2 x 2 er ist so ein Zentimeter mal Zentimeter der Ding ist dann so ein halben Millimeter dick.
Oder wo ein Plätzchen das ist wie gesagt dass das so auspressen rauskommt dann aber auch du schon die größten die du Chris mit Abstand also da hört auf.
Und Hauptzweck davon ist darauf dann selber neue diamanten entstehen zu lassen.
Hauptzweck von den Dingern ist tatsächlich in dem Bereich der Forschung Substrate für die Forschung zu machen.
Wenn du diese.
Hatte.
Ja also ist es ist deine Standard Probe auf der du mit der du irgendwas machst du weckst was da drauf du implantiert was da rein du machst irgendwas damit.
Ist mit Omas reagieren und nicht reagieren.
Die wie gesagt du die Standard Dinger sind so die kleinen dreimal drei Millimeter du kannst größere aber größere wird schnell teuer und brauchte meist nicht und es spätestens bei einem Quadratzentimeter hört auch irgendwann auf der Größe,
die Erpresser deshalb ist das was der erschreckt gemacht hat mit diesem Bierdeckel tatsächlich so wow.
Unter die die Größe vorher hört auf weil in diesen pressen ist einfach nicht mehr möglich also du kriegst da maximal so Kubikzentimeter raus.
Weil die Pressen nicht mehr Druck als.
Genau.
Größere Fläche.
Du bist nicht mehr Druck auf dieses Volumen gepackt.
Das hört da dann halt irgendwann auf das sind so die billigsten Substrate dann gibt's die die die schon nicht aus der Presse kommen sondern die aus solchen im present gemachten Diamanten mit dieser CVD Methode also ein Kymco vapour deposition gewachsen sind,
die gibt's in verschiedenen Qualitäts Abstufung und davon sind die die billigsten in denen sich Optiker great.
Optical great hat keinerlei Definition keine Norm oder so was das bedeutet das ist eine Kategorie die Elements ixmal eingeführt hat,
aber Element six hat so eine Marx macht schon seit Jahren dass ich das etabliert hat als das ist ein Diamant der diese Eigenschaften erfüllt.
Findest du auch in wissenschaftlich veröffentlichen da steht dann auch optical great drin obwohl Nieren wo definiert ist was Optiker great eigentlich sein soll.
Was ist das was Element six sagt was.
Genau das was das Element six & optical great verkauft das ist optical great.
Aber im Sinne von Dessau ausreichen transparent.
Ja genau die die sind halt die sind weiß also diesen Stunden sind durchsichtig wie ein Stück Glas.
Und die häufigste Verunreinigungen die in Diamant vorkommt auch in der Natur ist halt Stickstoff.
Und deshalb misst man sowas meist am Stickstoffgehalt die Sauberkeit also wie sauber der Diamant,
by optical great reden wir von Diamanten die ein Stickstoffgehalt von so um die 100 ppm haben also 100 Parts per million Stickstoff in dem Diamant Kristall.
Warum sind bei diesen Diamanten pressen kommen so viel Stickstoff drin wird das jetzt neu hinzugefügte das Teil des Prozesses lässt sich das nicht verhindern.
Das lässt sich nicht verhindern also es gibt welche die auch heller sind wo wenig Stickstoff drin ist aber diese pressen sind ja nicht im Vakuum oder so sondern die stehen einfach so rum du hast Luft du hast den Grafik drumherum du hast.
Warum sind die die nicht im Vakuum.
Weil diese Dinger ungefähr sowas nicht so die Presse würde nicht in diesem Raum passen so in etwa.
Okay das ist so typische Berliner Wohnung also 3 m hoch.
Ja ist die die Dinger sind riesig und es ist halt für den Prozess auch nicht leicht das noch in ein Vakuum zupacken.
Und die Ausgangsmaterialien schon der Graffiti nur vorher hast oder der der Kohlenstoff das war falsch ummantelte also die diese das sind so so Fällen in die das gepackt wird da halt über nirgendwo Stickstoff hinzufahren ist halt wirklich schwer.
Also das Stickstoff freizubekommen,
weil wenn wir uns überlegen selbst so etwas wie setze etwas 400 ppm Wasser so die Grenze dieser optical great ist,
wenn du bei irgendwie 1000 ppm oder so bist dann bist du schon weit bei dem gelben bei den tiefgelb das ist immer noch wenig also man sich das vorstellt 100 ppm.
Bei einer Million Atome sind 100 davon kein Kohlenstoff sondern Stickstoff das ist schon nicht so viel.
Über die aus der DVD die Sau also die direkten dark Base sind diese optical Great Yarmouth typischerweise irgendwas zwischen einem und 100 ppm.
Stickstoff drin die die Kosten dann so bei der Standard Probe 3 mal 3 Millimeter bist du so bei 150 € 200 € das in der Größenordnung.
Pro Probe ist schon wird schnell teuer.
So ist aber er ist noch nicht das Non-Plus-Ultra das Non-Plus-Ultra Davos teuer wird und das sind auch an die die ich eigentlich gebrauchte oder zum Teil braucht für meine Proben sind die sogenannten Detektor great bzw electronic Braid.
Ist das gleiche und 22 Begriffe die Element six benutzt meint aber das gleiche.
Die Elektronik wild Diamanten die sind die kannst du auch in 3 x 3 mm kaufen.
Bekommst du aber auch selten das ist auch so ein Ding das was du an Substraten kaufen kannst ist auch immer sehr also was du an Substraten kaufst ist sehr stark davon abhängig was ist denn gerade so gibt am Markt.
Engagiert.
Ja oder Element six dreht gelegentlich mal den Hahn zu wenn sie Bock drauf haben.
Was gibt einfach defacto keine anderes Unternehmen was du diese Bandbreite an Substraten anbieten.
Gab es lange lange Zeit nicht mittlerweile gibt's welche aber Element six ist halt immer noch so der Standard.
Die einfach etabliert sind und wo alle trotzdem zum Gucken und ja danke.
Genau die die halt auch eine Menge die halt auch so viel Macht haben das wenn mal jemand daher kommt der jetzt keine riesen Firma ist sondern so so Mittelstand oder so dann kaufen die den Halt.
Also dann ist der Weg.
Man kriegt noch Diamant Substrate so von Sumitomo z.b. stellt noch welche her und mittlerweile aus China kann man halt mal gucken aber das die Frage welche Qualität die Steine haben die man da so bekommt,
synthetischen wie gesagt das sauberste was Element six anbietet sind electronic great Diamanten,
die haben einen Stickstoffgehalt den gibt Element six an mit 5 ppb oder weniger 5 ppb heißt V Parts per million.
Was heißt bei einer Milliarde Kohlenstoffatomen sind 5 Stickstoffatom und drin das ist also noch mal da ist noch mal ein Sprung.
Es lassen sich aber auch entsprechend bezahlen die Elektronik ragecraft du meistens in 3 x 3 Millimeter oder kleiner.
Und die Kosten dann so pro Stück 1500 Pfund.
3 x 3 Millimeter und das ist dann wie hoch auch nur ein Millimeter.
Nicht nicht mal Millimeter sind 0,3 Millimeter meistens.
Also dünnes so ein Hauch von von Plätzchen und da liegst du dann was war die Zeit.
1500 Pfund also wann die letzten die ich gekauft habe und da war das Pfund noch was wert.
Ja nicht mehr lange.
Also da bist du also da bist du sehr schnell wenn du eine Proben Reihe mit zehn Proben machen möchtest du in der Größenordnung von dem Auto eine Mittelklassewagen.
Ja verbrauchst du dann diese will sie wären die dann die kaputt.
Ja da dann also du wächst doch was drauf ne dann ist da etwas drauf gewachsen und dann müsste ich dann sind die durch.
Ja ja okay dann ist durch okay aber medial verlasse ja dann noch mehr Diamant erzeugt.
Emittiert hast du mehr Diamant erzeugt aber du kannst da keinen weiteren mehr machen weil das ja das ist dann eine Probe.
Die benutzt du dann Günther suchst du wenn du eine Proben reinmachen willst sagen was du willst heraus also willst gucken wie wie wirkt sich denn der gesamt Gasfluss auf meine Kristall Qualität auf.
Aus dann machst du dann normal wenn Minimum fünf Proben weil du bist du irgendwie eine gerade oder irgendwas falsch daraus wird irgendwie Informationen haben dann hast du 5 Proben dir gemacht hast und die sind danach weg.
Ist sehr schnell sehr teure.
Wetter habe ich deshalb habe ich das in meiner Arbeit lange Zeit so gemacht ich hatte von den wasserarbeitsgruppe auch sehr arm ist oder gewesen ist als sie noch gab ich hatte zwei elektroniktrade Diamanten.
Unten kleinen Sack voll optical great weil die halt nicht so viel kosten seit ich habe meinen Prozess solange optimiert und solange dran rumgeschraubt weil mein Ziel war es möglichst saubere Diamant mit dieser Anlage zu machen.
Ich habe mein Prozess solange optimierten dran rumgeschraubt mit den optical great Diamanten bis ich mir sehr sicher war.
Das was ich da wachse sauberer oder in der Größenordnung von dem der Elektronik racist und dann habe ich eine Probe auf einem electronicved gewachsen.
Die ganze Untersuchung ja da kommen wir zum nächsten Punkt dafür gar nicht so leicht zu sagen weil es schwer zu messen ist.
Tatsächlich.
Alter Aufwand und man kann noch nicht mal nachprüfen ob es funktioniert.
Das ist sehr deprimierend das ist aber auch tatsächlich eine schwierige Sache weil du hast da Diamant ab und Kopfteil das 0,3 Millimeter dick.
Da wächst zusammen was zwei 300 Mikrometer drauf.
Jetzt willst du diese zwei 300 Mikrometer untersuchen dann guckst du mal okay womit kann ich den Stickstoff nachweisen warum kein Stickstoff Messner guckst du so und sistar.
Spin Resonanz dann merkst du ich kann mit der mit der Spin Resonanz aber nur den kompletten Kraftpfeil messen.
Wann ist das Foto drauf.
Und nicht das was ich darauf gewachsen habe das heißt ich kann den in die Maschine packen und sehe ein vorher und nachher messen und wenn nichts Neues dazu gekommen ist weiß ich okay,
ist schon mal so in der Größenordnung von dem was das Rad hatte mit sauberer ist sich das aber nicht,
was ich noch machen kann ist ich kann.
Ich kann anfangen mir gewisse Fehlstellen anzugucken wie ich vorhin kurz erwähnte gibt es ja verschiedene atomare Defekte im Kristall.
Eventuell auch mit Fremdpatronen.
Und ein sehr sehr prominente sehr gut untersucht es was auch für diese cubots und so eine wichtige Rolle spielt das NV4 stellenzentrum das NV4 stellenzentrum das besteht aus einem Stickstoffatom.
Und einer ja einen fehlenden Kohlenstoffatom du hast also deinen diamantgitter und dann irgendwas Stelle ist ein Kohlenstoffatom Quatsch ist ein Stickstoffatom und an der Nachbar Stelle fehlt noch zusätzlichen Kohlenstoffatom.
Das ist das was ich hier auf dem Arm tätowiert habe so als bedeute.
Gerade kann.
Ja was leider gerade keiner sehen kann aber genau.
Genau das dass wir Fett hatte ich toll weil das ein ohne jetzt zu viel erklären das ist ein quantenmechanisches System das leicht indizierbar ist.
Leicht auszulesen ist und leicht manipuliert werden kann mit Licht Mikrowellen und Magnetfeldern bei Raumtemperatur soviel dazu also.
Das Ding schon wieder nach 99 aus.
Genau dass das ist das ist genau das ist das ein anderer Ausflug.
Ja ja die.
Aber aber diese dieser dieses Fehlstellen Zentrum hier also diese diese besondere Anordnung Kristall die wird halt immer gebildet wenn Stickstoff da ist und wenn man den Diamant genug aus heißt also lange genug heiß macht er mir gerade gesagt dann heilen defekter aus.
Und immer die lange noch heiß machen diese defekte dann wandern und ausfallen dann treffen die gelegentlich auf sonnen.
Stickstoffatom bin ein Star ist und wenn die das Treffen dann bilden die halt diese diese Fehlstelle bis Zentrum das heißt wenn ich gucke wie viele von diesem Fehlstellen im Diamant sind habe ich so eine grobe Abschätzung wie viel Stickstoff drin.
Was heißt ich mache den Diamant solange heiß bis aller Stickstoff der da drin ist sich irgendwie einen hautzentrum umgewandelt hat und die kann man sehr gut messen weil die kann man mit optischen Methoden messen da ballert man mit einem Laser drauf und das leuchtet in der anderen Farbe zurück.
Simpel gesagt also ich drei mit dem grünen Laser drauf und dann kommt rot fliegt raus und das kann ich mehr essen.
Unsere mit diesen NV Zentren also das ist photolumineszenz.
Photolumineszenz Signal kann ich in meinem Diamant messen und zwar abhängig von der Tiefe also ich kann mit meinem Messgerät den Fokus meines Messgerät kann ich einmal durch den kompletten Diamant durchfahren.
Jede Stelle ab.
Und dann genau an hier an jeder Stelle abtasten und dann kann ich sehen dass das Signal dass da rauskommt ob das in meiner Schicht größer oder kleiner ist als in dem Substrat da drunter.
Damit kannst du wirklich sehen was ist jetzt eigentlich bei.
Genau damit kann ich halt sehen ob meine Schichten sauberer waren als das Substrat oder dreckiger.
Unser soll ich mir zum habe ich gemacht dass du noch die über die ich mich am meisten gefreut habe im Laufe meiner Promotion als irgendwann mal die Messdaten zugeschickt bekommen hab beim schwarzhans zu Hause weil,
ich konnte dort wunderbar sehen dass die dass das photolumineszenz Signal in meinen aufgewachsen in Schichten ungefähr ein Faktor 4 kleiner ist als in den saubersten Diamanten von Element six.
Was heißt ich bewege mich da irgendwo so im ein PPP Bereich wahrscheinlich.
Das sind die Freuden der.
Ja genau das sind die Freunde wissen.
Nur damit du auf der nächsten Party auf die Frage was machst du denn so kann es sagen ich bei mir wachse dir.
Ja dass das eigentlich die Prim das eigentlich deprimierende ist du musst jetzt eigentlich noch mehrere Experimente Hals machen um Hals das noch mal mit anderen Messung zu bestätigen und so weiter dafür brauchst du aber mehr substrate.
Mal gucken.
Also langweilig anruf ist ein bisschen ans Ende gekommen ist ein es gibt noch irgendeinen Aspekt.
Ja nein ich hatte doch ich hoffe es war nicht zu wir weil das ist.
Nee ich fand es nicht wo ich konnte ich konnte die mir zu weit gehen folgen auf wenn das jetzt schon klar dass mir jetzt so Anschluss bei der bei der bei der weiteren Forschung Geschichte die sozusagen jetzt mit Diamanten noch möglich ist normal im komplett neue Tür aufgeht,
die hat aber nicht unbedingt aufstoßen wollte so aber man versteht jetzt also ich verstehe zumindest,
was das Wesen eines Diamanten ist und was ihn sozusagen so besonders macht und das selbst,
in eine Situation wo man der Lage ist welche synthetisch herzustellen so Tank.
Fängt gerade erst an.
Da fängt er einerseits erst an und andererseits nimmt es sozusagen diesen diesen Nimbus dieses dieses Element ist eigentlich relativ wenig ist vollkommen klar warum nach wie vor davon so eine Faszination ausgeht weil es halt einmalig ist so weil weil.
Geiles Material.
Weil es einfach etwas ist was sozusagen auf diesem Planeten nicht so zu finden ist meine hätte jetzt vielleicht ein paar andere Türen aufstoßen können aber das nicht einfällt sowie die soll sich wie wie wie wie will man den hierzu schleift und bearbeitet.
Ada das ja vorhin gesagt oder dafür müssen was zu strukturwissen ne also wir haben diese diese Diamantstruktur ja also diese diese guitar,
die dieses FCC Gitter die zwei ineinander verschoben sind und wenn man sowas sehr stark symmetrisches hat also in alle Raumrichtungen,
dann gibt es da immer Ebenen,
wo weniger Kraft wird also wo wenn man in diese Richtung drückt oder da versucht zu spalten weniger Bindungsenergie ist als in anderen Richtungen,
man hat ja eine Symmetrie in irgendeiner Form dadrin genau aus diesem Grund kann man Diamant in bestimmten Flächen also ein bestimmten Richtungen leichter Spalten als in anderen Richtung.
Gleiches Material andere Struktur Beispiel Grafit.
Graffit kann man entlang also man so ein Einkristall hat die einzelnen Schichten voneinander trennen geht sehr leicht,
also diese Richtung kann man das sehr leicht Spalten zu 90 Grad dazu also Sonne da wo die wo man durch alle Schichten durch guckt war sie in die Richtung zu spalten fast unmöglich.
Und beim Diamant ist das ähnlich nur der Aufbau ein bisschen komplizierter.
Wie sieht man denn diese Struktur also meine wie spaltet man in der Nähe den Diamanten letztenendes.
Man man man sieht das an dem Diamant weil wenn du dir mal Bilder bei Wikipedia anguckst mal Spiel von so ein Diamant der hat Rohr gefunden wurde.
Auch wenn es ein auch wenn es einen ein Diamant ist hat er trotzdem schon man erkennt die kubische Gitter Struktur im Rohdiamant schon wieder.
Also betrifft alle wenn wir Kristalle malen also zeichnen oder so dann sind das ja häufig so so längliche mit zuspitzen oben und so,
diese Struktur die die Diamanten oder die Kristalle generell haben resultieren immer aus ihrer Gitterstruktur das heißt wenn ich so ein Einkristall in der Hand habe kann ich dir an der Form sagen des Kristalls wie da drin die Gitterstruktur liegt,
wenn ich dann weiß was für eines ist.
Also du du siehst zumal ich weiß gar nicht ob der der Deutsche oder auch der ja der deutsche Wikipedia-Artikel du siehst schon dieser Rohdiamant da oben das nicht geschliffen.
Dieses Bild an dem Artikel das ist schon sowas kubisches irgendwie das hat schon so eine Form.
Oktaeder essen.
Yaki da sind auch Daniela aber da da siehst du das da schon verschiedene also verschiedene es gibt verschiedene Ebenen die auf der.
Auf der Kristallstruktur resultieren und da weißt du dann dass du dann in bestimmten Ebenen halt das ganze Spalten kann.
Womit Spalt ist denn das.
Schwitze ich weiß.
Na wenn das so hart ist ist es ja trotzdem noch so hart.
Ja ja es ist hart aber es ist nicht so hart heißt ja nicht dass du es nicht halten kannst.
Ja okay gut aber Wetter ist mit der Zahnbürste rangehen in welcher.
Zahnbürste nicht aber aber wenn wenn wenn du einen festen Schlag mit dem Hammer drauf dann spar dann machst du den auch kaputt also hart also.
Hat Inhalt der nicht duktil also wenn etwas also diktiere ebenso so formbar Form also,
nur wenn du brauchst wenn du etwas haben möchtest was was lange hält und wirklich hart ist im Sinne von einem Hammer oder so dann willst du etwas haben,
das einerseits hart ist andererseits aber auch duktil also irgendwie Stahl z.b. nun Stahl hat wo sehr sehr viel Kohlenstoff drin ist also Stahl ist ja Eisen mit Kohlenstoff drin,
Rundstahl hast wo sehr viel Kohlenstoff drin ist so Gussstahl und so dann ist das brüchig.
Das ist zwar hart aber sehr bricht sehr schnell in Anführungszeichen wenn du aber etwas hast das weich ist mit wenig Kohlenstoff drin dann hält das viel viel mehr lass es aus weil bevor es bricht verformtes sich erst ein bisschen,
und genauso ist beim Diamant der Diamant ist zwar scheiße hart.
Aber Vati überhaupt nicht verformbar das heißt mit dem festen Schlag in die richtige Richtung bricht der Oder spaltet sich an der.
Aber nur in diese Richtung.
Bin auch nur an dieser Stelle dann sind wir so Keramiken die du hast die sind auch vom Härtegrad her sind die unglaublich hart trotzdem kannst du mit dem Hammer zu dämmern.
Stimmt das heißt man kann dann die Diamanten relativ leicht den Garaus machen aber wenn man einen Schlag ansetzt ist dann die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass es auch eine glatte Bruchkante.
Genau wie sehr hoch genau also Diamanten Diamanten schleifen und Spalten macht man immer entlang dieser also entlang.
Günstige Achsen der Kristallstruktur und da dann mit einem gezielten Schlag gefällt dann genau halt das ist das was die Kunst des diamantschleifen Stan ausmacht fällt genau an der Stelle dann halt entsprechend was,
bricht was weg und den Rest schleift man dann halt.
Womit schleift man den.
Kleinen Diamanten mit Diamantpulver also mit winzig winzig klein Diamant Kristall und Diamant Pulver entsteht entweder indem man große Diamanten zermahlt.
Oder die Diamantpulver kann man auch synthetisch herstellen da kommt auch fast alles aus Russland die Herstellung ist relativ witzig irgendwie weil simpel runtergebrochen macht man das in explosions Reaktoren.
Also ganz ganz einfach man nimmt einen Mann nimmt im Grunde so ein Reaktor so groß wie ein Haus hat da ganz viel Graphit rein und ganz viel TNT.
Und jagt das Gas in die Luft und dabei entsteht durch halt die große Hitze und den großen Druck entsteht Diamantpulver.
Neben ganz viel Rotz ganz viel Dreck und davor.
Jetzt bist du auch erstmal wieder raus gewaschen.
Und das Zeug wäscht und reinigt so auf deshalb ist das auch sehr teuer also Diamantpulver Diamantpulver ist auch häufig in Polierpasten und so drin das auch häufig Diamantpulver dran.
Mach echt dass ich scheiße teuer aber so nur sehr wenig so.
Genau so sehr wenig drin aber es ist halt drin also.
Wie Blattgold irgendwie einig auch teuer aber.
Genau gold auch eigentlich teuer aber so wenig das ist halt das kannst du auch mal auf eine Currywurst draufpacken.
Okay aber wie macht in der Diamantschleifer dann dieses Pulver also worauf irgend macht man das.
Der packt das Pulver auf dem Schleifscheibe sagen wir mal,
mit einer Emotion noch und dann den Kristall drauf und schleift den halt jetzt fragen warum funktioniert das,
das funktioniert weil von diesen 1000 in kleinen winzig kleinen Kristallen die Pulver vorliegen sind garantiert ein paar dabei die genauso liegen dass die gerade x Achse haben die sehr sehr hart ist,
im Gegensatz zu der die vom Kristall da drauf liegt,
habe von dem den du schleifen willst das heißt von diesem Pulver hast du ja statistisch verteilt alle Kristall Richtungen,
im TV kommen unsere da sind garantiert genug Kristalle bei die in irgend also die in der Richtung liegen die härter ist als die Richtung die du gerade drauf hältst.
Und deshalb kannst du den Diamant damit schleifen.
Aber es ist ein sehr langsamer Prozess.
Das ein sehr langsamer Prozess ja und auch eine Kunst das zu machen also Diamant Schleifer,
also der hat es ist so also Staffel so schwierig dass du jetzt bei denen Schmucksteinen und so der Schliff ein Großteil des Wertes aus machen kann also ein großer beschissen geschliffener Diamant ist weniger wert als ein kleiner der,
ordentlich geschliffenes wobei man den großen auch wieder runterschleifen kann also.
Aber ist halt eine Kunst und ist auch im Wesentlichen so in Belgien zu Hause die Kunst auch aber nicht nur.
Genau ja auch nee nicht nur du schreibst auch da wo billig ist ne.
Nee ich meine gibt es noch andere Zentren wo und wieso diese Diamant so eine Kultur hat wie ein Berg.
Nee das ist tatsächlich nur da,
Software bezeichnet es gibt verschiedene Konferenzen auch so wie es für jeden es gibt dass er so schön ist für jeden wissenschaftlichen scheiß gibt's Konferenz ne unter anderem gibt es auch diament also Konferenzen für Diamant,
da gibt es einmal die Diamond dies relativ groß die tot um die Welt also diesmal hier mal da,
immer sehr schön ich durfte einmal in meiner Karriere zu Diamond fahren von unserer Arbeitsgruppe aus der Badi in Granada das war sehr schön.
War ganz nett.
Und umgeben von Diamanten Herz.
Ja genau umgeben von Diamanten hat auf der Konferenz geht's dann tatsächlich auch nur um Diamant.
Aber nur aus der Wissenschaft.
Nur auf einer wissenschaftlichen Perspektive genau also da macht keiner Schmuckstein oder so sah geht's nur um halt atomare atomare defekte da drin um irgendwie potenzielle medizinische Anwendung jetzt nicht,
kapall Therapie sondern so die nanodiamant irgendwie als Träger für Medikamente,
und ähnliches also da gibt's wirklich nur um nur mit dem wissenschaftlichen Aspekt das ist halt die Dame Konferenz sie tut so durch die Gegend wie gesagt.
Die ist dann auch mal in den USA mein Japan mein Australien ich hätte ein paar Jahre später noch mal hinfahren können da war die in Bad Honnef.
Hatte ich mich so oft.
Bad Honnef Granada Wer macht eigentlich die Planung.
Ja das eine gute Frage.
Muss jetzt auch nicht wissen.
Die bei dem Geologen sind sehr viele Konferenzen auf Hawaii weil da ist ja viel vulkanische Aktivität.
Pferdeservice und beliebter Sport im Forschungsbereich ja wir mussten ja unbedingt irgendwo hin wo die Flugreisen billig sind und so.
Rein zufällig Tourismusgebiete,
aber die die II conference kein richtig Konferenz sonst läuft unter dem Begriff Workshop ist ein bisschen kleiner aber so die die heiße Zeiten die der der Diamant Community und das sind weltweit so lasse 3000 Leute sein,
die ist auch immer bei diesem zweiten Workshop mit diesem Workshop das so sind immer so Gruppen halbes Jahr versetzt also die Diamond Konferenz das andere ist der Diamond Workshop in Hasselt.
Und auch in Belgien.
Dann noch die Schleifer oder sind immer noch nur alle.
Nee alles immer noch nur Wissenschaft aber das sind so die beiden großen Konferenzen die man so mitnimmt wenn man was im Bereich Diamant macht eventuell noch die Karten aber da wird auch noch mehr gemacht als nur Diamant.
Okay und die Schleifer die machen gar keine Konferenz sitzen einfach nur rum und schlafen vor sich hin was ist ja dann wahrscheinlich wirklich so und so also ein Handwerk was.
Zum bisschen den Eindruck macht als ob dass das Letzte ist was ausstirbt.
Ja also es ist ein Handwerk aber es ist auch was was ich jetzt also ich nicht sagen würde das wird nicht mal von Maschinen abgelöst ne weil so mit einem Laser also die man kann Diamant schneiden mit Laser z.b.
Gut also was passiert in Münster warum kann der Leser dass wenn.
Du nimmst mit Infrarot Laser mit sehr sehr sehr viel Leistung also so ein paar 100 Watt.
Also nicht so nicht der Laserpointer mit 5 Milliwatt maximal Sonnenwinkel 200 Watt.
Sodass.
Ja genau und und den Dienst fokussierst du dann tatsächlich auf einen winzig kleinen. Und damit rastest du halt über den Diamant immer wieder drüber bis irgendwann du die oberste Schicht halt weg.
Gebrannt ja.
Die alte Brennerei.
Ja da brennst du das weg und du musst halt sehr sehr viel also du brauchst irgendwas im Mund Frau Roth Bereich am besten liegt und du brauchst mal was mit verdammt viel Leistung weil der Diamant ja zum Großteil eigentlich transparent also das geht ja das meiste geht durch.
Helmut du musst halten möglichen Laser neben der nimm den einem der Bande ist wo der Diamant nicht ganz so durchlässig ist aber da immer noch genug Leistung hat unser Zeug weg zu brennen.
Diamant mit Laser schneiden kann auch nicht jeder.
Ist auch ne also jetzt ist nicht so eine Kunst wie Diamant schneiden wie Diamant schleifen aber ist auch nicht so simpel wie man im ersten Moment denken könnte.
Aber für für Schmucksteine wird diese schleifen glaube ich tatsächlich nie aussterben weil es halt es ist ein Kunsthandwerk.
Ja also ein Laser also kann man mit diesem Laser wirklich was ich dreidimensionale schneiden demektir auf einen einzigen Punkt fokussiert oder ist es mir so ein durchschneiden.
Durchschneiden also die dreidimensionale schneiden.
Kann man was rein fräsen oder gibt's für dich nur um.
Du kannst rein fräsen wenn du willst kannst du mir lasersachen rein fräsen aber halt mich um die Ecke quasi also immer nur von oben drauf.
Ja aber könnte da so ein Relief reinmachen so.
Ja das geht.
So so so so mein Name auf einem Reiskorn aber mein.
Mein Name auf dem Diamant geht ja das würde gehen ich habe ja den.
Wahrscheinlich wird der pro Liste diamantstift muss ich sofort blingbling der der der Diamanten Welt.
Ich habe den saubersten Diamanten ich gemacht habe also diese eine wirklich richtig saubere Probe die rausgefallen ist auf dem electronic great.
Da weiß nicht vielleicht bricht davon ein kleines Stückchen ab und landet in einem Ring ich muss mal schauen.
Natürlich würde ich das Erbe nur nur wenn nur wenn der Hals dreckig über bleibt beim abschneiden oder sonst würde ich es nicht machen weil das ist ja Uni Eigentum die Probe.
Na ganz schön teuer.
Und die weiter das ist auch so faszinierend wenn sie so eine Arbeitsgruppe auflöst wo Proben.
Ja vorher dennoch km.
Nee man muss im richtigen Moment an der richtigen Mülltonne stehen.
Ja es hat mir nichts mehr ein.
Mir so spontan glaube ich auch nichts wir hatten ganz ganz kurz angeschnitten es gibt monddiamant noch da kommt auch durch genau wie bei vielen anderen Sachen auch durch Verunreinigungen.
Mit anderen Elementen also gelb ist Stickstoff grün sind Strahlenschäden aber man kann Diamanten umfärben wenn man den Atomreaktoren wirft.
Oder in die Nähe bringen,
durch Bauer werden Diamanten blau der Haupt Diamond zbbs tiefblau das war auch was was mich ein bisschen also irgendwann mal erstaunt hat weil ich immer gedacht habe vor eigentlich jemanden wenn immer dieses diese weißen was man halt so aus Film und Fernsehen kennt.
Viel seltener von aber wie gesagt die hier die bunten.
Was geht ab schwarzer.
Ja schwarze gibt's auch die sind gar nicht zwingend Diamanten das sind diese carbonaro ist oder Carbon irus oder so heißen die.
Ich beginne ein Diamant Diamant Carbonara.
Aber ohne Sahne bitte diese diese schwarzen.
Diese schwarzen Klunker ich muss jetzt nicht mehr gut machen wie die heißen carbonado heißen die das ist nichts trinken Einkaufsfallen sondern eher was polykristallines.
Oder häufig was was polykristalline.
Iris ist immer tschuldigung was ist immer was polykristallines was,
was vor schon mal gemacht haben etwas sehr ähnliches auch schwarz und zwar ein Anführungszeichen Diamant,
also so wie das DLC der ist ist auch schwarze verdiyse Mischform aus SP2 SP3 hybridisiert die haben DSC gemacht dass nur aus SP3 Hybridisierung,
Kohlenstoff besteht und das wäre im Grunde wenn man da also so ausdrucken möchte wäre das so was wie amorpher Diamant.
Alles hat dieser SP3 Hybridisierung der Atome hat aber nicht die Kristallstruktur von Diamant und das Zeugnis.
Sehr erstaunlich mal das härter ist als Diamant weil durch die durch diese amorphe Struktur.
Also dass ich dass die Atome nicht geordnet sind wie im diamantgitter sondern amorf wild verteilt und sich wild überall bilden und ganz komische Bindungswinkel haben gibt es keine Kristallflächen an denen man das Spalten könnte.
Wieder alles statistisch verteilt ist und deshalb ist das Zeug Hertha.
Dass das ist SP3 hybridisiertes DLC Kommandantur nicht vor synthetisch hergestellt.
Okay aber das ist dann wahrscheinlich wirklich das aller härteste was ist.
Nee ich glaube Kohlenstoffnanoröhrchen dicht gepackt sind glaube ich noch meine Nummer härter.
Aber da da geht man da da kommt man dann wieder im Bereich so wie misst man Herze mit welchem Verfahren misst man Herze weil diese Methoden wie sie Maschinenbau benutzt werden so Vickershärte oder ähnliches sind dabei hinfällig.
Vor allem kann man diese Nanoröhrchen ja noch nicht in den entsprechenden Längen wie man sie gerne hätte.
Ja die und diese Nano und diese Nanoröhrchen sind dann auch wieder ja es ist hart für diese atomare Größe nee du kannst doch keinen Block daraus machen oder so.
Ja nee war ja auch was anderes ausbauen.
Wir wollen weltraumlift haben.
Weltraumfahrstuhl haben.
Dann direkt Hörerinnen geneigte Hörer kann mal zur Unzeit man anderen Raumfahrt orientierten Programmwechsel habe ich habe eine schöne Sendung an den Space elevator gemacht und was es braucht.
Den.
Kann ich find das.
Adnan oral.
Ja ich ich fand ich fand die Folge auch sehr schön.
Und als ich erinnere mich noch als das allererste Mal von dieser Idee gehört habe weltraumfahrstuhl das für eine Nachricht mit Manni das Quatsch das kann funktionieren das ist so.
Und wenn es funktioniert ist es richtig totally aus.
Ja ja genau.
Genau aber auch dazu müssen wir in der Carbon Technologie noch ein wenig vorankommen.
Ja ich glaube ich hoffe wir haben nichts Wesentliches vergessen haben wir garantiert echt so lange.
Aber bestimmt aber dann trotzdem 3 stunden gequatscht und ich denke das reicht dann erstmal.
233 Stärke können wir noch 14 Minuten drauflegen nein ja passt immer wieder gerne.
Pastor Rainer ich sag vielen vielen Dank für die Ausführung hier zu unser allerliebster Freund gucken ich habe keinen Diamanten möglich gerade.
Ich überlegte ich bin jetzt will ich ob ich ein dabei habe ich hätte eigentlich einen mitbringen wenn ich habe noch ein paar nein ich habe ich habe tatsächlich noch einen ganzen ganzen Haufen also eine Schachtel voll mit bestimmt 20 Stück zu Hause liegen.
Weil ich eher ich schreibe dir gerade meine Diss zusammen und auf meine Proben die tatsächlich daliegen schön sortiert alle durchnummeriert und.
Läuse dicke clunkers Anhalt so.
Nee genau die diese diese diese kleinen diese kleinen Plättchen wo müssen wir aufgewachsen ist weil ich mit denen halbgerade von Labor zu Labor Single weil,
wie gesagt diese Messmethoden für den günstigsten gar nicht so leicht also das kann auch nicht jeder ist kein Standard Messinstrument das man kauft und dann das ist dann dann geh mal zu einer Arbeitsgruppe die machen nichts anderes als solche Messungen,
geh mal hin und frag darf ich das mal messen und dann,
man den das und dann klären wir das irgendwo auf und dann sitzt er so und dann messen die einem das halt aber mann mann tingelt halt tatsächlich durch die Gegend weil man will sowas nicht per Post verschicken.
Jetzt nicht was unglaublich wertvoll ist sondern weil er 5 Jahre Arbeit dran hängen wenn die weg kommen bei der Post haben wir halt ein Problem.
Diamanten transport ganz geheim.
Reitwiesner den Deckel zu.
Ja nur durch.
Vielen Dank Reinhard vielen Dank fürs zuhören ja bei CAE.
Polizistin arbeit ist es kann ein bisschen dauern hören uns bis bald.